this is Joo podcast number 403 with Echo
Charles and me Joo willink good evening
Eko good
evening I had the biggest fattest head
of any baby that was ever born into the
human species my head was and remains a
combination of the head from the alien
and alien and a prizewinning albino
casaba melon from the Iowa State Fair I
feel truly sorry for my parents Patricia
Shea Whitman and Robert Bob Wilson When
I imagined them cradling my doughy
gigantic in the rain soaked winter of
1966 on their houseboat in
Seattle I was one of those tots that you
see and gasp under your breath in
quizzical horror I wasn't one of those
babies that made it easy for viewers to
hide their surprised
revulsion I'm sure no one knew that I'm
sure no one knew what to say when they
saw my white bloated Macy's Thanksgiving
Day Parade head Ling about on my snowy
damp potato sack
body I was like some kind of larvae I
was the color of grub worms that have
never seen the sun picture an ashen
Manatee with a tiny human face now
picture this creature screaming to have
its diaper changed you get the
idea no you don't I need to keep going
I'm not sure if you fully understand the
large-headed pale horror of baby rain if
there were a maggot with vaguely human
features wrapped in swaddling clothes
that would have been me the University
of Washington Hospital probably bleached
the entire pediatric Ward after I left
due to my resemblance of a
life-size blood white blood cor pusle I
was like Louie Anderson with the head of
ET if the nurse at the hospital had
swapped me with a big eyed albino hippo
baby that would have explained
everything instead my parents were
handed a lumpy Jaba the Hut like infant
that made sounds like a calf being
strangled by an
octopus
me and that right there is an excerpt
from a book called bassoon king art
idiocy and other Tales From The Band
Room written by rain
Wilson and Rain Wilson if you don't know
besides being a large headed baby is an
actor comedian podcaster producer writer
director philosopher and I made the term
spiritual
Voyager you might know him because in
1997 he played Casey Keegan in the
iconic ABC Drama One Life to
Live in 2001 he played guy in
Supermarket on CSI for one short part of
an episode he was the janitor in an
episode of Law and Order in
2002 but he's most well known for his
portrayal of Dwight K shre of shuit
farms on the TV show the office now this
show came from the British version and
my wife being a Brit we had already
watched this program and we were
somewhat obsessed with the British
version of the office but the American
version of the office ran from 2005 to
2013 which were for
me some rough years there were some
rough years in there those were the War
years and I put my family through a lot
during those
years but we got through it through
deployments and distance and
death and one thing that no matter what
was going on one of the things that
always connected us was that show The
Office it was funny sentimental it was
reflective and we still watch it and we
reference it and we quote it and we are
thankful for the joy and connection that
that show brought us and we are thankful
to have R Wilson here with us tonight to
share his experiences and Lessons
Learned along the way rain thank you for
joining us Joo
Echo Bros I'm so happy to be
[Music]
here that was that was hysterical that
is some funny writing that's a
funny writing who wrote that that's
guy's talented your ghost writer is a
skilled
individual he did a great here or she
did a great job it is true though I I
would always see these baby pictures and
family pictures from like the late 60s
and I'd be like I'd be like that was me
I mean it I'm not exaggerating it was
like this watermelon headed my head was
the same size as my body it was
something really WR are your parents
large-headed at all or is this like a
ski to generation dad my dad's a you my
dad whole side of the family is
Norwegian and they call Norwegian round
heads and they that side of the family
is big round basketball heads no
question uh so let's talk about you
let's talk about let's start at the
beginning you're grown up you're born
with this obviously this giant head your
your your name is rain yeah legitimately
r a i NN y you the immediate reaction is
your parents are hippies yep and but
then they're a little bit old to be
hippies true hippies y a lot of lot of
people in the SEAL Teams you'd meet guys
that had weird names right and it was
just so obvious you know they'd be like
oh my name is whatever Harmony you be
like oh you know born in 1969 or born in
1970 the parents were hippies and they
just yeah that's where they're doing a
rebel against their parents by the way
because their parents are probably still
hippies right and so they're like I'm
going to be a freaking Commando they're
like Hey listen Harmony you can do
anything with your life what you want
but don't go into the military man so of
course 18 yes boom that's what we're
doing um what's up with your parents so
they they're a little old to be hippies
that's correct right it's hard to it's
hard to sum up my parents they're uh
they're a strange lot you know um they
weren't hippies in the sense of like
well my mom I think she did
some she did some alternative substances
shall we say but um but like my dad in a
weird way was very like he was very like
in later years very Reagan kind of
Reagan Republican and but at the time
and he was so he didn't have like the
long-haired kind of thing but he had the
kind of Bohemian artsy kind of thing so
he he's this my dad let me put it this
way for 20 some years my dad worked in
sewer
construction he was office manager sewer
truck dispatcher billing accounts Etc
like that total bluecollar guy yep then
put that aside he would get home put on
Opera and start painting abstract
paintings murals like crazy
fantastic stuff and then when that
wasn't enough he was writing like crazy
science fiction books that no one ever
read on the side and he was a member of
the bahai faith so it's this weird thing
of growing up and it's like this real
blue collar home we didn't have any
money at all I don't think he ever made
over 15 Grand in a year and uh we lived
in little rental concrete 900 foot
houses and yet we had this Bohemian
artsy kind of thing so that's what was
going on when I was born like they lived
on a houseboat he was a pancake Chef
when I was Chef he was a he was a short
order cook when I was born but he wanted
to be an artist at the same time so it's
just it was a it was a weird time did he
grw up in the Northwest as well no I
thought he grew up in like West Illinois
illo yeah Mom's from Wisconsin dad's
from uh Downers Grove Illinois and this
you what year were you born 6 six yeah
and yet in 1968 your your parents get
divorced yeah yeah and what are your
memories of that going on well I don't
remember any of that but that was a you
know it's one of the defining you know
events of my life when I look back on it
because I've been in a lot of therapy
around it but um yeah my mom uh took off
when I was two my dad then remarried
when I was
three um he moved to to Nicaragua I'm
sure you have your Nicaragua questions
there for we got freaking we got
nicaragu highlighted like a boss here up
the wazu but um yeah it was It was kind
of crazy cuz I he would never answer why
they got a divorce so I would say Dad
why did you and Shay she went by Shay
cuz she changed her name she kind of
went hippie she went all hippie yeah she
even joined like a weird like cult
called like well don't you kind of isn't
that part of the gig when you're going
full hippie yeah if you're going full
hippie there's got to be some kind of
cult membership um and then she worked
in an insane asylum in bismar North
Dakota um and she had a goat named Angel
of the Morning yeah so she went there
yeah she went there we used to do
training
there's a there's a site and I forget
what state it's in but it's an old
insane asylum so we used to go in there
and like clear buildings and do like ex
military type exercises but it was in
this the freaking creepiest place you
have all these freak Navy Shields and be
going through like everyone is on edge
freaked out scar shitless it's all weird
there's and there's some like old
dilapidated wheelchair in the corner
with like a blood stain on it and you're
like yeah there's old like you could
like weird gurns all it was creepy
creepy thing but that's where your mom
worked yeah yeah stuff like that so it
when I finally kind of I didn't really
see her very much between 2 and 15 um
maybe just a handful of like visits
where we'd have like a sandwich or an
ice cream cone or something like that
but then when I got to know her and
around 1819 I asked her why she uh left
my dad and what happened there and and
she admitted that she had had
Affair uh with a theater director cuz
she was doing experimental plays and I
never knew like why did I have this
impulse to be an actor like I didn't
know anyone that was an actor but I just
in my body like I always wanted to be an
actor I wanted to make people laugh I
wanted to do skits I wanted to do
characters and stuff like that and um
turns out I didn't even know this and my
mom had been an actor when I was a
toddler she had done the crazy
experimental plays where she'd like been
topless and like painted her torso blue
and run around in the audience I know
you've done a lot of that kind of stuff
Echo and um's already a
fan uh and she had an affair with the
theater director of the crazy theater
play and left my dad and left me
bigheaded toddler and um but I do want
to say like um she came back into my
life when I was 15 16 years old she
committed to coming back into my life
getting to know me she felt bad about
what she had done she wanted to repair
the relationship and she really worked
hard to have a relationship and uh and
atone for her mistake and and you know
this a shout out to anyone that's you
know had a kid and didn't raise the kid
for whatever reason no judgment you can
always come back it's never too late and
she made a big impact in my life when I
was a teenager like she had a big heart
she really knew about emotions and she
put her arm around me and just talked to
me how I was feeling and no one in my
existing family did that at all and it
made a big difference and probably I
wouldn't have been as successful as I am
today without kind of a mom coming back
into my life and from like 16 to my
early 20s like really being with me in
that way and one thing I noticed about
this and I I was going to talk about
later but I'll bring it up now so I
found it interesting that your dad like
kind of didn't tell you and to me that
seemed like the right thing to do like
if I was to get divorced for my wife and
my wife did some heinous things and my
kids were little I wouldn't I would try
not to be the dad that's like your mom's
a filthy disgusting I would try notore I
did I would try not to be that guy
because I would think that the best
thing you could do is try and give them
the best possible image and when they
grow up they'll figure it out it seems
like that's the the move you hear about
this all the time you hear about these
painful divorces and you hear about both
sides putting the kids in the middle and
like bombarding the kids with like well
your dad did blah blah blah blah blah
with the secretary well your Mom stole
all the money and spent it on the blah
blah blah and the you know these poor
kids are being traumatized in the middle
like it was and my mom Shay was shocked
when she said and I remember I'll never
forget the expression on her face I'm
like I like why did you guys really get
a divorce and she's like you me your dad
never told you salute to your dad and uh
he didn't do it he didn't say one bad
word about her not one bad word and uh
and she broke his heart God and dude
you've got this picture that your dad
Drew in the
book and again this is things that the
book is hey get the book this book you
got another book out called Soul boom
this book is called the bassoon King get
the book it's freaking fascinating to
read but you got this picture in there
that your dad Drew and it's like
it's like disturbing it's like your
dad's like laying on an altar and
there's a woman and she's got a knife in
her hand and it says like it's an
operating table and it's like he's being
like tortured by her as like this naked
doctor it's very it's very crazy yeah
and but your dad never told you never
told me no that was that uh you know he
he had some real Integrity around stuff
like that you know um in fact I will say
like my dad rarely said bad word about
anyone that's such a good way to be yeah
I recommend that course of action for
for pretty much all humans yeah um you
mentioned okay so your dad gets divorced
your dad gets custody which I guess you
you probably didn't know how that was
happening but I guess if your mom's
doing all this crazy stuff he was
probably able to make it work he which
never happened in 1966 hell no hell no
babies didn't go with dads yeah no yeah
I mean maybe it was just the fact that
she couldn't have supported your head
carrying you around and was like no
option he had enough upper body strength
to be a manage they looked at you and
they're like
no but he gets he remarries some a woman
named Kristen yeah and like you said
they moved to Nicaragua you said there's
some highlights you definitely got some
highlights from Nicaragua here's some
highlights from Nicaragua I remember
Kristen getting caught in quicksand on
the muddy Beach and being pulled out of
the sinkhole by a guy with the tree
branch I remember a friend of ours
emerging from the ocean after a swim he
was screaming and falling to his knees
covered in jellyfish tanks I remember
running and flying kites on the hilltop
with the local kids all of them Barefoot
me and giant rubber boots that cheese
grad my ankle bones I remember devil day
the local equivalent of Halloween when
terrifying men dressed as Devils in
outfits adorned with wings ran around
with fireworks they would chase kids
pick them up and scare the holy B Jesus
out of them by tickling them and
screaming in their faces I was so
horrified that this would happen to me
that I refused to go outside I'm pretty
sure this was the work of the Catholic
Church turning a fun Pagan Festival into
a helpful traumatic reminder of of the
evils of Satan I remember Bulls being
driven and herded up and down the mud
streets in Nicaraguan by Nicaraguan
Cowboys who lived in the jungle I
remember the best oatmeal ever made
served up by our cook Antonia and the
fresh and the taste of fresh shrimp and
fried plantains what's that plantains
what's a plantain it's like a it's like
a banana kind of thing but it doesn't
have the sweetness and they fry it up
you haven't all Central America is
really big all I I've only been to
Central America a couple times went to
Panama yeah that's it you go through
this list of the freaking animals and
you got mosquitoes dogs parrots you had
a pet sloth named Andrew
yeah yeah how do you get to keep a pet
sloth is that
legal probably not there weren't many
laws around there I mean Nicaragua is
pretty Lawless state but then the
Caribbean coast of Nicaragua which by
the way theovon is a buddy of mine I
watched his episode with you talked
about Nicaragua but that area Bluefields
is where I lived where his theon's dad
we're going to do a Nicaragua trip at
I'm going with you would you provide
Security provide security you in echo's
going okay
um yeah so it's a it's a really Lawless
part of Nicaragua I mean it's it's it's
there's Indian tribes that wander down
from the swamps and there's Cocaine
Cowboys and uh it's all different they
don't barely speak Spanish there it's a
lot of Creole a lot of English and it's
crazy Germans and uh it's it's pretty
nuts out there there's crazy Germans in
Nicaragua yeah yeah on that in that
little part in that little chunk yeah
are these the ones that couldn't make it
to Brazil or what maybe there's a maybe
there's a Nazi con I didn't even think
about that theovon is a
Nazi maybe his daddy vaugh yeah was from
there so anyways it so there weren't
many laws but what were we talking about
like oh the sloth oh the sloth you guys
had a pet sloth the legality of that the
the most hysterical thing which I I have
vague memories of the sloth in the cage
but I don't my dad would always tell
this story that they would put my the
sloth in the cage and then every morning
they'd get up and the bars of the cage
because sloth's obviously super slow but
really strong right kind like Echo and
the bars would be pulled open and the
sloth be there but they're so slow that
they just had to like walk around and
they knew within like 30 or 40 ft and
then he'd find them in a shrub and like
pick up Andrew and put them back in the
cage and go Bend bend the bars back and
then repeat that every single night but
I think eventually they just put them in
the jungle and let him go uh are we
going to talk about the worms yeah let's
talk about you going to go there I well
is it a bit much we got oysters we got
amibas we got monkeys we got and then we
got worms which is like you really you
want to go there there I don't know that
you do I mean the one quote that I self
edited and self censored was the opening
line which says my most vivid memory of
life in Nicaragua involves worms coming
out of my butthole I'll let you take it
from
there I was going to leave it out you
know sometimes you write things when
you're younger and you're like this is
so edgy and flashy but now I was going
to do the courtesy and we're not going
to put it in there but you know you
brought it up obviously this is a fond
memory of yours you got a tough
listening audience I think they can
handle
no it's it's it's not that it's just I
had worms most people have worms you get
worms down there that's what happens you
know the little eggs are in the water
bins and whatnot and uh then you take
deworming medication but you know what
happens to those pesky little buggers
well they got to come out somehow
they're not coming out this way so I
remember uh walking down the
street and then all of a sudden and I
was to my Kristen my stepmom I was like
mama I gotta go poop and it was
like and then I reached down and pulled
out a worm longer than this then this
knife wiggling and there were a bunch of
neighborhood kids around and they saw
this happen and they were like and I
threw it on the ground and I I forget
how to say like kill it in uh in Spanish
but my stepmom was like M orte or
whatever to kill it and like some kid
came out with a shovel and they were
stab abbing it and and crushing this
worm that had just come out of my butt
and then they laughed at me and mocked
me and that's why I have the personality
that I have I I mean um I don't know if
normal people I don't know what that
what that does to your brain you should
have ended up in the your mom's asylum
in North Dakota I know I needed some
treatment Evolution yeah
um so you get done with the worms you
end up moving back to Washington State
in 1971 that's your next move and you
weren't really quite sure it seems like
why you moved back there like what was
the reason for that they just ran out of
money uh in Nicaragua they my Dad tried
a bunch of different V business ventures
uh he had an oyster farm for a year or
two so he was they had just oysters choc
a block with oysters and he was shipping
them up and sending them to like nice
hotels in managa and then shipping some
back to the United States and stuff but
there was so much corruption that
everyone wanted a piece of his profits
you know and he couldn't make it work
and they just they kind of ran out of
money and came back so he got a job in
the sewer company the in her family
sewer company oh convenient nice yeah
you say this in the book my family was
poor not food stamps or Haiti poor but
poor we rented a two-bedroom cinder
block house with a dirt yard in Olympia
my dad got a job working with kids at
the high school it was a program for
juvenile delinquents and troubled teens
just out of jail he taught art in
English and Spanish Spanish and made
$5,600 a year I truly have no idea how
we lived off of that Kristen was a
housewife as most women were in those
days and had never learned to drive for
some reason so she was truly a
stay-at-home mom I remember my dad's
Shaggy juvies often dropping by the
house in their bell bottoms and leather
fringed vests Kristen would stare as if
the Manson family had just stopped by
for a chat here's how I remember our
poverty we drove an old used edel from
the 50s and then a 1972 powder blue Ford
Pinto replete with exploding gas tank I
drank powdered milk instead of regular
and got all my clothes from the
Salvation Army I had about seven toys
and 11 books and stared in awe and
wonder at the grip at the nip knops and
the Rockham socs you don't remember G
from the 70s no I didn't have them it's
like a it's a toy and it sends a little
pingpong ball sort of thing you and they
had it's like stretch Armstong and I
remember those yeah it was one of those
gpops yeah that one slipped by me
normally when I'm reading stuff like
that and I see something I don't
recognize I I look it up I didn't do
that with G ginops you really did not
come prepared kind of a kind of a
shortfall rock and sck and robots and
light brights and lawn darts and
twisters and vibrating electronic foot
Electric football sets that the other
kids in the neighborhood played with we
never took vacations and eating out was
a complete luxury when we do usually
Bob's Big Boy Shaky's Pizza or this
crappy restaurant that overlooked the
local bowling alley where I once found a
rubber band in my cheeseburger we never
owned a wash and a dryer and our weekend
was always marked by a major trip to the
laundry mat where Kristen washed her
clothes for the week and I wandered
around trying to fish quarters out of
the
machines yeah so there you go there you
go the good times good times and it's so
funny because you don't I didn't feel
that poor I mean my friends had nicer
toys but I wasn't going living my life
like oh we're so poor mhm uh but it was
I wonder how old kids are when they
start to realize like what money is and
how much they have or don't have isn't
that a junior high adolescent thing
where all of a sudden like you have this
like you're 12 or 13 you have this like
burgeoning realization of like who you
are and how you fit in like oh I
remember like being 12 and like
oh I'm one of the nerdy kids oh they
don't they all don't like me and they
don't play with me and like and like you
know that realization of like where you
fit in the social strata you know and
like not only I'm nerdy I'm poor and
nerdy it's like H you got to hand me
down pants in the whole nine yards so my
parents were both School teachers which
is uh not a high-paying job and you know
I mean but you always had a job you know
that's what was nice like my parents
always had a job and so we always had
food you know I remember but we didn't
have like the cool stuff you know like
everything that you just mentioned like
that electric uh football thing what you
set up your moves and your plays I saw
it but I never had it never had the
Rockham sockum
robots the I think one of my sisters had
the light bright thing light bright
making things with light it's fun making
things with light bright I remember all
the commercials from the early' 70s yes
and your your family obviously had
enough money to have a TV we had a TV
because you talking about TV and this is
again how old are you right now 56 57
yeah 57 okay I turned 52 in a few days
um so yeah all this stuff is like very
familiar to me welcome to the 50s man it
sucks everything starts going downhill
everything's been going downhill oh um
Adam's Family Mash All in the Family L
and Shirley Threes Company Happy Days W
krp in Cincinnati and Taxi
I'm assuming that you just watched all
these television shows all the time
because that's what we did yeah that's
what that's what when I say we I mean
the United States of America it was like
we yeah collectively that's what we did
it's it's interesting now everyone talks
about parents you know with kids and
talk about like screen time like
limiting screen time because now there's
so many more options like my son can
open his phone and he can go on social
media he can play a game you know or app
or he can watch YouTube which has 18
billion videos on it you know or he can
get Netflix on on his phone or he can
turn on a TV or he can turn on his
computer do this you know there's just
all these options
70s black and white RCA turn it on and
just three channels and then whatever
was on was on but boy they knew how to
do those reruns and uh yeah it was you
know one of these
I want say I was a latch key kid because
my my my stepmom Christian was at home
but it was the TV was just on from 300
p.m till I went to bed at at 8:00 p.m.
and it kind of raised me and kind of
taught me about the outside world and uh
we don't have to get there now but I
talk about this in Soul booom about how
two of my favorite television shows from
the
70s uh for me were kind of taught me
about
spirituality and uh you want me to go
there go for you talk about I can
cross-pollinate the two books do
whatever you want man so um Kung Fu was
a show a lot of young folk don't know
about because it's not played it's it's
so boring to watch is why but it's
brilliant so Chinese Shaolin monk
martial artist Kung Fu Master goes to
the old west and wanders around he's
looking for his brother so he's always
encountering like these racist guys and
like a aggressive mean guys and he's
very peaceful and he tries to like solve
all the conflicts but then there has to
be a couple of ass-kicking fights
throughout the course of the show and
the other show that meant so much to me
was Star Trek I just I love that
original series I saw every episode like
10 times um I I had one or two Star Trek
books that had like how the ships worked
and stuff I memorized it and to me I was
kind of when I was writing more about
spiritual themes later on in Soul boom
this last couple years I was thinking
about these two shows as like a a
parallel of our spiritual journey
because kung fu is like our personal
spiritual journey that we all have we
are all we have our skill set we have um
ways in which we you know deal with
forces that come at us and we seek to be
wiser Kinder gentler to grow our
spiritual qualities as we go about our
our individual path in the world but the
Star Trek story is interesting because I
find it to be a very spiritual story
because it's about Humanity has gone
through World War III and uh which was
horrific and it's come together United
as a species on the planet and out of
that unity and they because of
Technology like the replicator they're
able to feed everyone the the races all
get along and um they're able to go out
in outer space and boldly seek got new
life and new civilizations and this is
like the the collective spiritual
journey that humanity is on and that's
one of the points of the book that I
make in Soul booom is like we don't put
enough focus on that story like when
people talk about spirituality they
usually mean
Church uh or they mean some kind of like
I do these three or four things to kind
of make myself feel better like
meditation or or whatever read inspiring
quotes or whatever and you know I'm
going about my spiritual path I'm trying
to be just more peaceful in my life
let's say but we don't kind of have a
conversation about like hey where are we
going as a species and how can we
spiritually evolve collectively to kind
of make the world better and what is our
individual responsibilities to making
the world better not just making my life
better and my family's life better but
expanding that vision of what our family
is and and trying to make the world a
better place and we do that in lots of
different ways you can do it through
your church you can do it just on a
Community level you don't have to do
some you don't have to feed starving
kids in Africa I mean you can but you
don't have to do stuff like that but
that we all have a role to play and a
kind of a certain spiritual
responsibility and that was really
taught to me by by Star Trek and
thinking about thinking about that
Collective Journey uh where Humanity has
kind of matured and kind of realized its
full
potential it's interesting to think
about when when you sit here and talk
about
that you would think that look everybody
watched Star Trek right and how many
people miss the whole idea of hey work
we're working together to try and go
towards a more common beneficial
scenario and with Kung
Fu it's just interesting to me that or
what does it take and I mean I guess I
kind of know your life story a little
bit from reading your your books
but you not everybody gets there you
know not everybody gets there there's
people that are
just mad there's people that are they're
not happy unless they're undermining
someone else or taking from someone else
or make who you know I I know known many
people like this in my life
and it's interesting to think about like
I'm thinking about again having just
read your books and thinking about even
what you just said about your mom coming
back back to you when you were 15 or 16
years old and how that had such a big
impact like what if she didn't if she
didn't do that is that the thing that
made you start saying oh you know she
helped me I should help other people or
I should feel good about oh this is
where I this is what I'm supposed to be
doing this is what I should be doing and
and you just wonder where
those where those holes that don't get
filled
in what do they get filled in with if
they get filled in with something
negative if your mom would have come
back and been like Never Should I F you
you little Bast you know whatever would
you have been would you have taken a a
left turn instead of a right turn or a
right turn instead of a left turn yeah
yeah that's that's fascinating you know
I I love that that whole way of thinking
and and you know part of the you know
sometimes therapy gets a bad rap I think
people are
more understanding of it and appreciate
of it appreciative of it these days but
it's been one of the Great great things
about therapy is to kind of unravel this
really complicated childhood that I have
and had and be like how did it lead me
to be the man that I am today and doing
the work that I'm doing today as a goofy
actor as a Storyteller as a producer but
also as a writer someone who's
interested in kind of spiritual themes
and topics as well you know how did that
how did that come from but I do think
that you know a lot of parents want
their kids to like do good or do good in
the world or give selflessly or whatever
but the parents aren't doing it and I
think we learn it from the people around
us you know you hear people about that
do great work you know in service to
others and they'll be like you know why
do you do that well I saw my grandfather
doing that or I saw my dad doing that or
my mom would always go to church early
and do the the meals at the soup kitchen
or or whatever it is that um you know we
mirror that behavior so it's super
important for parents to understand that
that they you know it's Deeds not words
you know you got to practice what you
preach and uh so you know I had a lot of
people around me that were trying to
make the world a better place in a lot
of different ways I grew up a member of
the bahai faith and you know bahis are
often working trying to make the world
better and doing service work and um
looking at B look at service itself as
an act of worship so um that idea that
you know we give to others is is really
the ultimate just like in Jesus's
example you know you know serving the
poor and the
downtrodden is is a kind of a a worship
uh in it in and of itself so you're
putting this
together post situation but in the 70s
when you're watching Star Trek you're
just like this is freaking cool yeah
it's just cool yeah laser guns beat me
up uh and then you you got this again
you got this section in your book we
talking about comic Sidekicks you go
through all again all these characters
that characters that I grew up with as
well Squiggy from Lever and Shirley
radar O'Reilly from Mash Reverend Jim
Ignatowski what a great name from Taxi
Les nestman from WKRP hores Shack from
Welcome Back Cotter you you you you go
through those characters and you
actually have a a guest author that
comes in write Dwight K sh comes in and
writes his opinion of each of those
which is which is really funny uh get
the book and and it's weird too like you
mentioned your dad was you know doing
his day kind of blueco collar job and
then he's doing this kind of wild stuff
at night writing all these books and
doing this art you you've got a list you
got a list of of the books that your dad
wrote and I got to run through these
titles ghosts of ya is that how I say it
I have no idea you have idea ghosts of I
curse of ganm the chromium kid the
Subways of er Clarissa of Tomb Arizona
hospital I don't know how that one fits
into it all the I'll explain Arizona
hospital it's set in the far
post-apocalyptic future and the only
places the only institutions that are
still working are hospitals so there's
like Arizona Hospital Minnesota Hospital
Virginia hospital and that's where
humans have congregated to fight off the
legions of mutants that are always
attacking the hospital and the lead
character's name was Romeo Sierra which
you know from call signs Romeo Sierra
and that was that was the hero's name
and most of these don't even exist
anymore I don't know what happened to
all his it was before like word
processors he was on typewriters he was
writing these things and not to mention
now you have Amazon publishing so he
could have written these things and
publish them tomorrow afternoon and they
might have done well and people could be
like oh my God have you read tentacles
of the Dawn which is the one that did
get published do you have a copy of
tentacles of the Dawn I I anytime they
come up on eBay now I shouldn't tell
people this I buy tentacles of dawn so I
can have it in my collection but yeah
I've got like seven or eight tentacles
of dawn we have blown out books you know
I've covered some old kind of historical
out of print books and then they're just
gone yeah and I would I would buy a
couple copies for you know $4 or $3.99
or something and then we do a podcast
and they're $280 or $350 so yeah if you
are looking for tentacles of the Dawn
right now good luck you're going to pay
a pretty penny for damn you
Joo and meanwhile you're nerding out um
and I think you say this in the book uh
before nerding was cool yours fullon DND
D Dungeons and Dragons you are Ragnar
the radical who this is your character
that you play 11th level fighter Adept
with both bow and sword with a moral
alignment of chaotic neutral with a
chaotic with a with a moral alignment of
chaotic neutral which meant he could do
whatever he pleased how ingenious was
that the inventors of Dungeons and
Dragons that you had a moral alignment
of your characters lawful good which is
like paladins chaotic good which is like
uh I don't know the Lone Ranger like
he's doing good but he's off on his own
just kind of doing it in his own way not
part of any structure and then there's
neutral chaotic neutral lawful neutral
then evil chaotic evil and so you know
the dungeon master you know if you if
you start to do Behavior that's
different than your moral alignment than
your moral alignment changes and the
dungeon master can change that so it's
it's fascinating I love it you didn't
you didn't nerd out in the you didn't do
D and D come on you beat up the kids who
played D and D didn't you Joo well I you
got to you're because your name is Joo
and it's not like nerd
sordo uh my buddy Jason Gardner who's a
seal with with me for many many years 30
years he did but he's like heavy DN in
fact he's no stranger to putting on a
putting on chain mail and picking up a
broadsword and poke picturing putting a
picture of himself on uh on Instagram or
whatever but I so I remember d and d and
I probably tried to play it like four
times or something and was just I just
couldn't I couldn't get into it Echo
Charles could you get into it did they
even have it in Hawaii I vaguely
remember something I don't know but I
dig it though I dig it so
that's the most freaking politically
correct answer you've never heard of it
but you dig it okay cool I see what
you're doing over there the the chaotic
neutral you all this I I saw that
Spectrum somewhere and I was like oh
that that makes sense but I didn't know
where it was from yeah so now I do there
but you talk about in the book you're
you guys are full on full on hey have
you ever seen laring oh
sure H have you ever done it I haven't
done it but I've I've watched it I've
gone to laring I've gone to laring
festivals I don't know what they call
them yeah I guess they call them harping
Festival I'm a spectac I'm a spectator
I'm like the popcorn I'm like hey down
here in San Diego they have like a b and
speaking of Jason Gardner he would send
me pictures like once a year they have
like full contact fighting with swords
and shields and stuff like but it's not
play you you can see videos on YouTube
and it's it's real and people get hurt
and they get like their arms cut off
yeah so that sounds cool a little bit
You' you'd be into that if you could
actually bash people in chain mail with
a morning star or
something that does sound like fun uh so
we would get out of we would get out of
school no joke this is not an
exaggeration we would get out of school
3 o'clock by 4 o'clock we were at my
friend Sean Higgins house and I remember
Sean Higgins house because his parents
were uh divorced and the dad was a fruit
uh importer importer exporter of fruit
so they never had any and they were
really poor big Catholic Family Suburban
Seattle there was never any food around
but they always had boxes of fruit
everywhere and a lot of it was going bad
so it was like stale fruit stale
basement fruit so but it was cool
because we could go like you know like
hey do you have any food it's like we
don't have any food but we got this
crate of
pears you know oh cherries just came in
so we would like and we just be
like and uh rolling the 27 roll the dice
and eating fruit and occasionally we'd
Splurge for a pizza but we would play so
we would play from on Friday night 4:
till
11 um Saturday morning we'd reconvene
like 10:00 a.m. and play till 11 12
however late we could make it straight
some you know we'd get some food in
there somewhere Sunday we would meet
again like 11 or 12 after I think after
he went to church after Sean Higgins and
his brother Tim Higgins who was a
dungeon master after they'd go to church
we' play from like 1 to like 6 and then
from 6: till 9: at night that's when we
did our homework for the week how old
were you at this time that's just like
between 10 or 11 and like 13 14 so
multiple years many years of that yeah
yeah two or three weekends a month was
that schedule damn yeah just getting
after that D and D oh just it's all
about the treasure it's all about the
loot and is it leveling up it's all win
can you can you win no winning it's it's
like life Joo hey I just keep going
forward wait I just remember something
from uh from DND D stormbringer was this
a sword stormbringer I remember a sword
called stormbringer yeah stormbringer is
a title of here I'm going to nerd out of
a fantasy novel by Michael morock about
elich of Mel Bonet and his sword was
called
stormbringer and that was a stormbringer
series of books so good memory uh those
are from Daw books uh from like 1968
through 78 and uh that was a big
inspiration for D and D but that Soul
you do not want to go laring with
stormbringer because if it kills you it
sucks your soul into it so no afterlife
forget the afterlife stormbringer yeah
there's something about naming weapons
some occasionally guys would name their
machine guns oh I don't know if I like
that and my friend had a he had a he had
a machine gun and his I I think it's the
best name ever he had a machine gun his
name was roadblock and I just thought
that was epic that's pretty cool
roadblock he be like don't worry I got
road
block uh okay so you're full on you you
going full on this nerd stuff um and if
people think I'm making fun of you this
is all self- admitted nerd activities
right cor I have no problem with this I
own this yeah chapter five I was not a
Navy SEAL okay can we just like yes sir
can we just get that out of the way can
we just say that I don't know how to hit
people you know I will thumb wrestle the
out of you but I stand down I I do
not accept this challenge this is
roadblock right here yeah road block
F uh chapter five cuz just when you
don't think it could go anymore nerd
chapter 5 the
bassoonist I ask you to savor the
following sentence for several years off
and on I was a member of the following
clubs at school marching band pep band
Orchestra Debate Club Computer Club
chess club Model United Nations and
pottery
Club oh yeah note the the above list
does not include any of my
aforementioned role playing gaming bah
High youth activities medieval weapons
sketching kung fu movie Obsession or
vast Columbia record and tape Club
cassette collection featuring Journey
sticks Asia and Aro Speedwagon and you
do a big tangent about the whole uh that
whole scam the Columbia record tape Club
I remember that thing too I never got I
couldn't afford the whatever even get in
the program in the first place and
then if that wasn't enough I decided to
play the bassoon boom Universe explodes
then implodes then explodes again
quickly folding in on itself only to
create infinite other bassoon shaped
universes
so the bassoon what's up talk to me
about the bassoon you want to get into
bassoon look I don't want to get into it
but maybe a brief description would be
good all right get into it let's go no
man here's the deal you start you start
out and ban I'm on the recorder that's
cool then they're like okay pick your
instrument you know in sixth grade right
did you guys play it all it's ban at all
I I I made it to recorder okay recorder
not pass recorder you didn't go to
trumpet I got a guitar I got a bass and
a guitar
yo let's go um so then I went to
clarinet okay whatever and then I played
a little saxophone on the side and then
I wanted to play saxophon saxophones are
cool and I talk about that like the
phone section they could wear Hawaiian
shirts and have sunglasses kind of like
Bill Clinton was going on like doing the
Rockham s rock and roll saxophone right
and uh uh and then I so I said to the
band teacher whose name was and I'm not
kidding you his name was John Law John
Law yeah yeah and I was like Mr law I
want to play the Sachs and he's like
we've got enough saxs players but I've
got something really cool for you I have
got an instrument everyone is gonna flip
it's amazing it's so cool it's called
the bassoon I was like oh I was very
susceptible at that point you know after
my long 48 hour weekend long Dungeons
and Dragons I wasn't thinking straight
I'm like sign me up he profiled you too
like this was he got right into yeah he
was like the girls are going to be all
over you they're going to be licking
your
bassoon sorry sorry Mom so bassoon is a
big double read instrument you assemble
it it's like this big you you hook it
around your neck and it's and it's it's
pretty big you know and then it sounds
like
this so I spent many years playing the
bassist I actually got pretty good and I
was like uh you know it's another you
talk about these Life Choices there's
another there's a parallel universe
where this guy is a professional
bassoonist with the St Paul Symphony
Orchestra yeah so thank God I dodged
that bassoon
bullet uh now despite all this Nery
you're still kind of you're still doing
some Rebel is type things you're forking
Lawns and toilet papering trees um you
get rolled up by the police at some
point I do yeah I spent my time I did my
time I spent 11 minutes in the Lake
Forest Park Washington police precinct
my parents being called at 2: in the
morning cuz we were
out we would do we called ourselves the
taco terrorists because we would do
unusual things to people's Lawns and one
time we would we would Taco do have to
do with tacos oh okay we would go to
like a buy stale tacos in big in bulk
and then we'd put them all over we get
like um shaving cream and make like
shaving cream tacos and cover people's
Lawns with
tacos so we we're imaginative a you
target
like from school yeah
yeah sometimes friend like
friend like they're really our friends
but we kind of like wanted to get them
and sometimes it was like just the the
jocks did they ever seek
retribution no not really did you guys
maintain anonymity we did except to the
police the that crack police force of
Lake Forest Park Washington that
arrested US arrested us we went into a
7-Eleven at 2: a.m. to buy eggs and
bought out all the eggs from the
7-Eleven and the the the cashier guy was
like hey uh Marty down in the precinct
we got a bunch of 12-year-olds buying
eggs at the 7-Eleven at you might want
to roll up on this and and they we got
some reports of uh people's houses
getting toilet paper let me uh search
your pockets here I and we didn't know
like our rights be like hey you can't
search me what's the probable cause here
and uh so then we got put and then the
parents got called and that was it yeah
but I did my time man I've been there
the big
[Laughter]
house uh 1982 you're 16 years old and
you end up moving to Chicago again this
is all in the book funny ass stories
details are in the book get the book um
but you end up moving to
Chicago and there's a transition that
happens here yeah especially a musical
well we'll start with a musical
transition so you know it was Billy
Squire and it was Air Supply and it was
sticks and it was other
lame music yeah you get to Chicago and
you actually didn't cover really where
this introduction came from but you get
to Chicago and all of a sudden it's
violent F it's h scoo it's The Clash Joy
Division Psychedelic Furs b52s X Joy
Division English Beat Talking Heads and
Black Flag yeah right on hell yeah yeah
there was how did that happen well it's
this it was this weird con that was
being played in the American people and
it may not have happened in California
because people in California were cool
but in Seattle in the late 70s early 80s
the only way you could get music was
through Columbia Records and tapes club
or and because no one had any real money
to go buy into a record store and we
bought some records but even at the
record stores you couldn't find punk
rock or New Wave or indie rock or any of
that kind of stuff and um the radio
stations KY and KISW all they played was
classic rock rock rock which is pretty
awesome I love my classic rock but
that's but there's this whole other
world going on at that time you know
that we just didn't they didn't play any
of those songs and so I I wrot I'll
never forget like this girl I can't
remember her name I've got to figure out
her name from from my Seattle school
she's like listen to this and she gave
me a cassette tape and it was early
police like Zenyatta mondada on one side
and it was The Clash like on the other
side and then she gave me another
cassette later it was like Elvis
Castello and like early kind of Talking
Heads that was way more Punky and I was
like oh my go I had no idea that this
world of Music existed that was angry
and crazy and I me we got some like
Black Sabbath stuff but not like this
really smart edgy weird experimental
music and so I was I I was all in all of
a sudden on that so so that actually
happened while you were in Seattle yeah
and as I was leaving yeah it was the
summer that I left and then you get so
you get to Chicago and now you're kind
of like into that music yeah and so I
change up my whole wardrobe I get rid of
my nerdy wardrobe I bought a tie with a
piano keys on it the skinny one and uh I
had a SCA tie with the checks you know
the SK like English bead specials and
um and uh yeah I were like a it was a
John Hughes movie I basically walked
into a John Hughes movie essentially
that's when you got to Chicago yeah this
is also kind of uh I believe where the
the acting thing started cuz you're in
Mr rotenberg's acting class yeah and he
want he tasks you guys is does everyone
take acting or do you enrolling acting
was it your elective did you just get
thrown in there cuz you were late this
is one of those things where i' always
you know we talked ear about like all
the comic Sidekicks on the TV shows that
I used to watch for whatever reason even
though I never met an actor in my life I
didn't know that my birth mother had
done
acting I just had this I want to do that
I could do that I I don't know what it
was I don't know where that comes from
God or comes from within I don't know
it's like I want to do that thing that's
what I want to do and so here's my
chance we go to Chicago has a great
theater Department in this big high
school in the suburbs and I sign up for
an acting class that's really my first
acting class and then um uh yeah so our
first assignment I'm the new kid with my
piano tie and he assigns uh it's called
Uh public and private or private and
public or something like that like how
would how would you act in your room
just be what you would do in your room
so I brought in a like a record player
and I put on Elvis castello's song
mystery dance and um and I put it on and
then no knew me and I just went ape
because this is what I would do in my
room I just was like dancing around and
like air guitaring and thrashing around
and pogoing and um and it brought the
house down and all of a sudden for the
first time in my life Joo
Welling
um girls talk to me Y and all of the
cute girls in the acting class came up
and were like hey Patty me hey you're
you're new here here from Seattle nice
piano tie will you sit at the lunch
table with us we sit over here say hi my
name's you know and and I would meet all
these girls and and they were just like
that was so funny that was so great and
I was just
like and I was like that's it the
bassoon I'm in I'm all in with the drama
nerds now and I found my tribe you cover
this in the book I had crossed over
not from the movie cliche of unpopular
to popular i' had crossed over within
sub genres you see I had moved from the
regular old geek nerd to the very top of
the geek nerd hierarchy drama geek nerd
and the reason that drama Geeks are at
the Pinnacle of the food py pyramid of
geekdom it's not the tragedy comedy logo
or cats pins on the raincoats it's not
the black eyeliner on both the boys and
the girls neither is it the ability to
burst into s song or a tap dance in the
school hallway at the drop of a theater
reference no the thing that separates
theater dorks from the rest is one word
you guessed it girls there were and are
and always will be pretty girls who sing
and dance and act and improvise and joke
around and are willing to make fools of
themselves and this is the most
important point of all and they're
willing to hang out with geeky guys and
even go to rap parties and occasionally
make out with them this sets up drama
Geeks as the Lions of the Dork
serengetti
so that's how it went down huh yeah
that's how it went down yeah no looking
back at that point are you doing any
sports at
all no no Sports just PE PE you know you
put your you put your clothes that you
wear all week M and then you forget to
bring them home on Friday so you're like
ah it and then you wear them the
next week and they just stink and you're
doing kickball and stuff like that so
but you know I I I played some sport I I
play uh I play tennis play tennis yeah
and your grades are good yeah straight a
straight A's yeah are you try you're
trying in school yeah I try yeah smart I
read books yeah um you have a rock and
roll band yeah you don't play the
bassoon in your rock and roll band no I
don't I'm the singer the band is called
collected Moss right cuz a Rolling Stone
look at you
see we were horrible horrible two gigs I
think we had two gigs yeah not bad could
be worse could be worse um you so now
you start applying to colleges you get
rejected by Brown you get rejected by
Stamford yeah you get rejected by
Oberlin is Oberlin in the league of
stord brown you just threw it in there
for balance I don't know screw them
they're weird they're weird they're
weird cornfield
hippies uh but you get into toughs yeah
and TS is great school did you go visit
it yeah you went and visit it and you
loved it immediately what did you love
about it I mean it's like it was like
seeing those movies of like what a
college is you know it's like these
buildings and churches and trees and a
quad you know and dorms and it's like
this pretty little New England kind of
vibe and um and they had a really good
theater department so you're thinking
theater yeah yeah yeah I I wanted to
secretly be an actor I was studying
international relations psychology
English but really I wanted to uh I knew
I wanted to be an actor but I just I was
on the fence about how to how to take
that move you know to fully
commit you had a roommate Rob oh like I
think I'm paraphrasing but basically a
long-haired muscly dude from Arizona
yeah yeah he's like exactly the kind of
guy who listens to your podcast
yeah sounds like an awesome dude yeah no
it was it was cool I I'll just tell the
Rob story real quick so I move
in my uh dorm room and there's this guy
shoulder length hair like built um he
came in his truck he drove from Prescott
Arizona to Boston he's got his
guitars I think he's got a gun rack I'm
not sure if he brought his gun to school
he's got uh Jethro tll posters all over
his half of the dorm room and like some
velvet curtains and stuff like that and
his bong right and we couldn't be more
different he doesn't talk to me for two
months and finally he admits finally we
start to talk and finally he admits like
oh I I I found out you went to the
suburban Chicago high school that was
kind of wealthy and someone told me like
oh those are that's a rich douche dou
bags go so I thought you were a rich
douchebag so I didn't talk to you for
those first two months but then after
that we became really good friends and
it was awesome we hung out a ton and
he's a great guy I think he's a chef now
he's like a well world-renowned Chef
somewhere hair still looking good I
think the hair's gone yeah that's a
bummer yeah it happens um you you you
kind of talk through the what we talked
through already this is when you kind of
were now really reconnected with your
biological birth mom you kind of get the
backstory on all that um and finding out
that she had gone through this whole
acting phase
yeah do you think that made you think
this is sort of genetic
thing I mean what else could it be I
mean I I mean my my parents were really
great and that they supported me in
doing the Arts you know a lot of parents
you know kids have an artistic
inclination like that's not practical
and they kind of shut it down my parents
were very supportive CU my dad really
wanted to be an artist and he was kind
of like he was kind of a failed artist
right because he didn't he didn't really
apply himself he didn't try and get his
paintings out there he didn't like
really try and publish his books like um
so I had this inclination but I you know
I didn't know any actors or anything
like that it was it was mindblowing to
me at like 19 to find out that my
birthmother had been an actor for
several years and I because I was again
I was just filled with that long to go
to go down that road
so it's got to be genetics right I don't
know did it scare you at all like your
dad is kind of tried the art thing but
not really getting it done your mom
sounds like she kind of tried the art
thing and now she's not kind of really
getting it done did you think so you
know we make these Life Choices we don't
know how they they go down but here's
one thing that I do know that if you
want to be a professional artist you
have to
devote yourself to that craft to that
art to that discipline um hardcore
you've got to give it 10 years and
you've got to work 16 hours a day at it
and there's no other way I mean there
are some actors that have stumbled into
it and other artists that have kind of
fallen into things and that's all fine
but that's not that's not the standard
right so here I am growing up I have a
failed artist dad kind of a failed
artist mom and I know I have this
longing to do acting I'm pretty good at
I'm not like this Prodigy but I'm pretty
good at making people laugh and playing
characters and and stuff like that and
that's when I'm like okay rain if you're
gonna do this you have got to give
yourself to it and commit your life to
it and your work to it and your 100% of
your focus um otherwise you will never
make it so I in that way I'm grateful
for what my parents taught me from what
uh from what they didn't do and the
choices they didn't make I remember
having conversations with my dad when I
was like 12 or 13 I'm like how come you
never go and try and sell your paintings
like oh well I went once or twice and
they rejected them and I just don't have
all these excuses and even at 12 or 13
I'm like no just take your paintings go
down to art galleries and you know knock
on the door and say hey I got this
really cool paintings you should sell
them and he would never sell himself so
when I find made the decision to be an
actor I knew that this was going to be a
really important decision because I was
going to have to go all in there's no
half-assing it and you know you got to
put both feet in and so I applied to
acting schools I left College I was at
that point I was at the University of
Washington in Seattle and um you know I
auditioned I moved to New York City I
was 20 years old I didn't have a pot to
piss in I had like $37 in the bank and
you know I went to NYU and went to
acting school I'm like I'm in it to win
it and I'm going to do 10 20 years as
long as it takes uh I'm I'm all in but
I'm so great I'm grateful because I knew
what the alternative was that if you
just kind of try it and like it but
don't fully go in I see where that road
takes
you and it's also no guarantee that you
could go 100% in and you could dedicate
your entire life to music art uh acting
and you can still be working as a waiter
or whatever I was I spent the first 10
years of my life as an actor an artist I
never made over 20 grand in a year first
10 years of working as an actor because
I was mostly doing theater I couldn't
get into TV in film no one would
audition me because I was kind of weird
looking and they didn't know what to do
with me so um yeah and but I just kept
going I just kept going and then came
out to LA and then got some jobs and and
then you know ultimately the office but
you know there's a lot of times I was
thinking about about pulling the plug
and you apply so you applied to juliard
M and you didn't get in I didn't get in
no and then you you auditioned at NYU M
and there's an interesting thing that
you talk about in the book you you're
doing the c c monologue from long day
Journey Into Night which I went and
watched on YouTube because I do research
things when I when I don't know what
they are but I went and watched somebody
doing it um it was interesting a woman
named Zelda fiter fit Chandler fit
Chandler she told you like take all the
performance out of it yeah yeah so it's
like you were going over the
top I was acting I came in with my
audition I was like I forget the first
line it's like you told me stories about
your life do you want to hear some of
mine they all have to do with the sea
here's one actually that gosh and then I
and then he tells this monologue about
being on this boat right which really
happened to eug O'Neil the playright he
was a Merchant Seaman and sailed around
the world on these boats so he was
telling this story and you know I did it
and I did my performance and seen you
know and she's like okay shut up stop it
like just then there was a guy there was
like the dude there the dean like just
pretend he's your dad look at him and
just just say the words I start again
you told me some St no stop just just
talk to him like okay you told me no no
no right just literally just talk to him
like you're having a conversation I was
like you told me some stories about your
life you want to hear some of mine o and
then she's like good keep going they all
belong to the sea I remember one time
when I was on and I connected with I
started to cry like I was just he
started to cry like we had this like and
I was like oh that's what acting is
it isn't all this drama club it's
like and and so she was like Boom come
to New York
kiddo so now it's on
1986 yeah New York City yeah New York
City at that time was
Mayhem
uh drugs everywhere no idea they talk
about now like on Fox News the
deterioration in the American cities
which is happening but dude go to New
York in 19 in the
1980s crack epidemics graffiti every
wear
dilapidated you know empty lots broken
bottles people I mean it was it was it
was nuts this is when I was going to New
York so I was a kid I was grew up in
Connecticut and I was like uh into the
hardcore scene into the punk rock scene
and so I was going into New York City we
take the Metro North train down it cost
$8 I'd bring like 20 bucks for the
weekend $8 to get down $8 get back $4
for a pizza yeah and we'd go to cbgbs
we'd go to whatever shows were going on
we' go to the new music festival we go
to Just Mayhem but that place was
totally insane at that time yeah it was
crazy like walking through Time Square
was I'm not kidding you took your life
in your hands I'm not kidding every four
steps that you took somebody offered you
crack or Coke or whatever like literally
every four steps EO Charles dude they
would go I would go down on eth or 9th
Avenues cuz I had a girlfriend that was
living in New Zealand and I buy stolen
calling cards remember calling cards
like a Sprint calling card and you'd
have to dial an 800 number and then in
order to make and I would buy stolen
calling cards for like 20 bucks but I
would get $200 worth of calls off of
them but they were I mean they were
offering like here's stolen license
plates do you need a passport I mean
there was you could get any the dark web
was on the street was on the street the
the hookers would be out it was crazy
like we'd go to a show we'd leave at
9:00 at night or 8:00 at night to go to
the to go to a show somewhere um in on
the Lower East Side and we'd be walking
and you see the the hookers out and
they're like looking nice ready for the
night and then we'd come back at 3:00 in
the morning and they'd still be there
now they're looking like you know
they've been working all night it was
freaking horrible to see absolutely
horrible and so New York was totally
insane at the time you got you say
mugged Slatt attacked a couple times
there you got you got hit in the head
with a stick by a random dude and you
got gay bashed which I which I found
interesting yeah I got gay bashed yeah
yeah I um I couldn't sleep and I went
walking like 1:00 a.m. I was living in
Chelsea at the time uh which wasn't even
a gay neighborhood really at the time it
kind of became one later but uh it was
kind of they used to sell drugs up and
down seventh and eth Avenue so it was It
was kind of dangerous this is
88 and um and I went down and there were
a couple of guys and they they were like
called me I don't know what I can say
the FW and uh maon and some other things
and they just started swinging at me and
I wanted to be like I'm straight
no but I for for some reason I was like
I did your jiu-jitsu's like they
couldn't land a punch on me for some
reason I got so instantly I didn't I
didn't punch back but I was
like it was like slow Mo Matrix it was
like have you ever had that happen in a
fight you could kind of see it like and
then I took off and they gun jumped in
their car and they took off after me
these are determined dudes they really
wanted to bash some gays that weren't
really gay kind of gay like Metro SE
half Metro I kind went to Metro bash and
uh I ran down like 13th which was the
wrong way and then I crawled under a
staircase under by some garbage cans and
I like pulled the garbage can back and I
was like
and I was just yeah and I stayed there
for like 45 minutes and then made my way
back it's brutal what do you do at
acting
school well
Joo what do you do an acting school
people watching this are like what the
hell can you bring back a general please
to talk about leadership I'm trying to
figure out like what do you do in acting
school now I will say this uh acting is
not easy because people think it's easy
right people think I could do that and
then they try and do it and they look
like idiots yeah it make and the really
good actors make it look so simple they
make it look like Brad Pit one of the
best actors in the world he makes it
just look like just effortless it's
really hard to do what Brad Pit does
really hard and that's what they
teach you at this acting school thing
although he never went to acting school
but terrible example but yeah so you
know the whole thing in acting school is
we're going toach teach you how to be
theater artists and theater actors and
from that you can do TV and if you have
that skill set you can do TV and film so
that it wasn't really like on camera
stuff we did a little bit of that but so
we did Shakespeare we did clowning we
did circus skills we did which is all
about physical kind of courage and
daring and kind of putting yourself out
physically out of your comfort zone we
did tight RPP trapeze juggling does
everyone do this is these like the
General qualifications for
acting everyone in this program did did
it and it's again you know there's some
you know fat kids in there that couldn't
really walk on a tight rope or whatever
but you do what you can you know and
you're supported but you do voice you do
speech and you do scene study and you do
stage combat so we did a lot of like
sword fighting like we're doing a
Shakespeare play and learn learn how to
do that which comes in handy when you're
shooting in film and you have to pretend
combat and stuff like how to take a
punch or fake a punch you know that kind
of thing and um and you the main thing
you do is scene study where you go and
you you work with your scene partner you
memorize your lines you come in and they
they give you notes on it and stuff like
that and there were some amazing
teachers and I was really lucky and you
played Hamlet uh
twice yes yeah how's that yeah we we did
Hamlet they cast me as
Hamlet uh which was incredible
experience and then the guy who directed
was directing it was really bad director
and I was totally lost and we would have
a rehearsal and then he would give me a
grade on how I did in the rehearsal so
he would write out a thing like so is
this a course that you're taking no it
was just a side play on the side of the
courses we would do plays on the side of
evenings but it's part of the college
yes part of the college doing plays but
you get no credit for it it doesn't
doesn't work like that it's just like
you're going through this program and
you're there from 900 in the morning
till 11: at night every single day well
five or six days a week and part of that
is doing plays so it's not really
picking and choosing courses this kind
of so he I went to the main acting
teacher I was in
tears um because I was like I'm so lost
I don't know how to play Hamlet I don't
know what to do and then he came and
watched some rehearsals and he's like oh
this guy's an idiot and he fired him and
he took over so we shut down and then I
had another chance we had done like two
weeks of rehearsal shut that down and
then Ron vanl a amazing acting teacher
came in and then he directed me in
Hamlet and it was an amazing experience
there's something like 30,000 words that
Hamlet speaks in Hamlet yeah H how do
you go about memorizing
that so I knew I was going to be playing
him like in the winter and then over
Christmas break I memorized all of the
Hamlet mod monologues I memorized all
the the soliloquies to be and not to be
that is the question and um so I came in
and then I memorized a bunch of his
longer
speeches before we started rehearsing
but what people don't understand about
like the memorizing lines first of all
when you're 22 it's way easier you can
memorize things really quickly but
you're spending hours on your feet
saying the lines and listening and
responding and trying it in different
ways and so it's getting in your body
you know what I mean it's you're not
just kind of like it's hard to memorize
when you're just sitting there with a
book and you're just like trying to
memorize it that's almost impossible but
when you're you you're on your feet and
interacting with people and stuff like
that so we did a big cut down version so
it's probably only 20,000 words um we
cut Big scenes out and stuff like that
but it was a lot it was a lot yeah I
went and saw a version of Hamlet and man
it was impressive oh cool where'd you
see it right here in San Diego yeah
great theater in San Diego yeah I saw I
saw one version at the old Globe which
was like the cool one uh well normal one
but I also saw another version at some
like other place and it was all modern
and crazy yeah but both those dudes had
to memorize a lot of words yeah the
thing that why one of the reasons
Shakespeare is famous he's famous for so
many different reasons and that's one of
the things that makes him so amazing why
people are obsessed with Shakespeare
but the fact that in 16
1800 he's written this play Hamlet that
is all about psychology it's as modern
as Freud and young and any psychologist
or any Christopher Nolan movie that
involves psychology in this in 16001 he
wrote that and it's all about who am I
Life Death should I live should I die
should I kill this guy why am I doubting
I should kill him I was told to kill him
and I don't why is that it's my own
failing do we have souls like I'm in
love with her but should I tell it like
it's this all this stuff and that's why
that's what made him like Head and
Shoulders better than anyone for
hundreds of years it's not until check
off you know two 300 years later that
all of a sudden playwrights are like and
Ipson and strinberg are like going into
that psychology we covered Henry V on
this podcast which obviously makes sense
but I was going to do Hamlet and I had
an um an actor that I was that I met
that I was like and who had played
Hamlet and I thought oh if I can get
them to come on that would be kind of
Epic and it just didn't haven't pulled
it off yet yeah but maybe you're that
guy let's let's do it I'm I'm a
middle-aged doughy white Hamlet you
know uh so so that's what you're doing
you're doing this that sounds like a
long ass day every day that's what
you're doing yeah you you graduate from
NYU and there's one thing that you
explain um there's like a Dr it sound
like a draft that happens at juliard
where you do like a couple a couple
performances or something or a couple
monologues or something it's like the
NBA draft I've never heard it compared
but it is what it sounded like yeah and
so you go into this NBA draft thing or
the theater draft thing top schools go
to this theater and juliard and we
perform little scenes for all the
casting directors and producers and TV
folk and people that run theaters and
there's I mean there's maybe 500 of them
you know the who's who of you know in
both theater and TV and film watching
was totally nerve-wracking you know I
was 23 years old my scenes kind of
sucked um I didn't do very well and I
didn't get I just played Hamlet this
this is this is a good story about how
Show Business works these agents pretty
good agents had come and seen Hamlet
they loved it they called me in
immediately they're like oh my God your
Hamlet was amazing that was so great and
they talked about it we talked about it
they're like okay you'll do these League
performances they call and then we'll
call you back in and and then I bombed
at the league performances like I didn't
do very good and then they wouldn't
return my calls and they didn't bring me
back what's a league performance this is
that juliard thing where the NBA draft
for actors was called that's what they
called it were do you and you you go
through this in the book but this is you
trying to be like Mr serious guy kind of
well it was me just trying to an agent
right that's what it came comes down to
and the the moral of this story is like
these had seen me play Hamlet
and then they see me do a couple of
two-minute scenes and because I don't do
good in those they don't want anything
to do with me but you had seen me play
three hours of Hamlet and that's kind of
how superficial the business is yeah cuz
in my mind it seems like if you can do
Hamlet you can kind of do anything it
seems like you'd think but you know
getting to what your other point about
like so I had this like wrong idea about
what it was to be an actor and that's
partially nyu's fault because I was
still you know kind of nerdy weird uh
different kind of guy and I was trying
to be like Mr theater guy you know and
so I had this idea of like this is who I
need to be and what I need to be and how
I need to present myself and um so it
took me several years and a lot of
hardship to kind of figure out uh and uh
you know I had a seminal experience that
kind of showed me my my road as an
actor your first acting job um at least
from what I could decipher from the book
was 12th night for Shakespeare in the
park you got paid $210 a week mhm so
that was kind of what you're doing out
of the gate yep uh eventually you joined
something called the acting company yeah
founded by John hman is John Housman the
guy that uh
uh used to do those commercials yeah he
did the commercials uh then what was
that show that he was in the paper Chase
the Paper Chase what was the paper chase
about cuz I remember about the lawyers
in Harvard like trying with a really
tough Professor trying to he was the
tough Professor the ultimate tough
Professor he was
like when EF Hutton speaks when that
when EF Hutton yeah Bo listen so you he
worked with Orson Wells he was a big
theater Titan he started this company
called the the acting company and I did
two and a half years of bus and truck
tours of Shakespeare
plays which is freaking hilarious in the
book you're talking you're rolling into
like whatever town in the midwest waterl
Iowa you've got you roll in at 900 p.m.
at 10:00 a.m. you've got a show in the
high school cafeteria and at 7 p.m.
you're at the downtown local Civic club
and you're doing these Shakespeare plays
to places that have never seen
Shakespeare before maybe or not for
years or something like that audience is
that it was cool it was cool and hard
and sometimes sucky and but I loved it
you know was 24 25 at that point I was
getting $515 a week so I was rolling in
it and plus you're getting this
experience yeah so you roll into waterl
Iowa what Shakespeare play are you doing
is it like a variety show yeah we had uh
no we did Romeo and Juliet um and 12th
night no and Two Gentlemen of Verona and
then the next year we did Midsummer
Night Dream so yeah did you ever perform
to like seven people and four of them
walked out it wasn't that kind of thing
but we would do a lot of like high
school theaters and high school like
cafeteria theaters you know where the
theaters up in the cafeteria and they
open the curtains and they're all
sitting at the and like we would have
food thrown at us and stuff like that we
had fun though we had fun it was hard
and you know I'm pictur when I was in
high school if we if I was in that
situation I would have made it really I
wasn't I would have been like such a
dick I'm sorry yeah sure but I was just
an idiot you know like school assembly
yeah Joo be there at 10:00 a.m. to watch
a two and a half hour version of Romeo
and Juliet and you're just like the kids
like things yeah but um the weird thing
about Shakespeare and I pointed this out
when we that was one the first podcast
we did was I think it was number 15
actually but I was cuz when I when I I
studied a lot of Shakespeare when I went
to college and it was like oh you're not
supposed to understand this you can't
understand this it's written in Middle
English it's like it's it's it's not the
same language and you have to there's
some similarities obviously but you need
to actually look up with these words and
understand the structure and and then
you go holy this guy is incredible
but you got to get people through that
transitionary period cuz they look at it
they go I don't know what the hell this
means and if they say oh oh yeah I read
Shakespeare it's great no they're not
they're lying cuz you there's words you
don't know yeah you have to look them up
thir words you don't know exactly so I
can't imagine if you tried to present
Shakespeare to me in high school I'm
sorry I'm such a loser well you you cut
out a lot of the stuff that just makes
no sense and then you um you try and
it's so hard to read Shakespeare on the
page and a lot of people get turned off
reading it but you've got to hear it
because when you speak it with intention
and like you're like you're trying to
get something from someone and so you
say blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah and you hear it in context it
starts to make way more sense and you
you you have that experience right when
you've seen these Productions and stuff
for
sure so you're kind of the other thing
we would do on the road games we would
do Insane games to keep us sane um one
of them was past the battery so we'd
have a little like doublea battery
and it would have to go around to every
single person in the cast so over the
course of the play you'd have to figure
out ingenious ways you'd Shake someone's
hand and there all of a sudden there'd
be a battery in it you're like oh and
then you you go to someone else you put
your armor and you drop it in their
pocket and like so the battery is making
its way around the other thing we would
try and do is we would take we would
find out the mascot of whatever school
we were at and then we would try and
everyone had to incorporate that word so
if they were like the Badgers you know
you'd have to say I say Thee I pray thee
Le
for when from when thou come surely th
thou thou are no Badger to say that thou
and we would always try and the kids
would be
like really is the word Badger 17 times
in this Shakespeare play it was that was
fun we did like we would do
withered hand where at some point
everyone had to have like a withered
hand on stage and Bunny Hop we would
have to at some point incorporate a
bunny hop um we got in bad trouble but
we had a lot of fun we had a lot there
was a lot of debauchery on the road too
I'm say and uh that kind of leads into
this next section I want to read from
the book it says here for an artsy East
Village actor there was simply no room
for God morality or devotion or at least
none that I could conceive of at the
time in my quest for this tantalizing
Bohemian street cred during my first
year at NYU I dyed my hair jet black and
started smoking a pipe the hair dye I
got from a box of clar all midnight
black you know the kind so toxic that
there's an emergency 800 number right on
the Box in case you accidentally dump
the concoction into your eyes I looked
ridiculous the first issue was that I
had forgotten about my eyebrows the hair
on my head was like Bruce Lee's and my
eyebrows were light brown with ginger
highlights I looked like a serial killer
who had just written his Manifesto on
the walls of his cabin with his own
blood and feces and the pipe my Aunt
Wendy my dad's sister smoked one always
had she was rebellious artistic pipe
smoking inspiration and I always loved
her rebellious artistic pip pipe smoking
Spirit as with most things in my life I
was simply trying way too hard we were
such a pretentious lot us Village artist
I remember having one ridiculous late
night conversation with a bunch of pot
smoking arites where the question was
posed would you ever do a
commercial I remember a friend of mine
paused dramatically and considered this
disgusting capitalistic question quite
deeply stroking his goatee and drawing
on his camel light I might do a
commercial and then he added headle for
soy
milk so so you guys were freaking yeah
we were douchebags no question no
question uh you you have to find you
always find the most embarrassing thing
about me in the book not the cool stuff
you find like the most humiliating I
thought these were the cool
Parts no get the book there's so many
there's like like I said I mean I'm
reading less I don't know probably 5% of
the book there's all kinds of insane
funny stories and like I said your ghost
writer did a great
job damn you Joo I wrote Every Word
every word I
say uh at some point you start fast
forward a little bit now you're dating
like a lawyer drug dealer I believe you
gave her the name
Jesse
um your cocaine comes into the picture
you say I spent countless nights in
drunken stumbling and almost vomiting in
taxi cabs speeded speedily through
parties and bars wafted redyed and high
through many late night conversations
and woke up desolate fried embarrassed
and sad on countless mornings during
those years good Bohemian
times it's weird because like I said I
was going to New York at this time and
like I would see these people I probably
saw you I I in fact if I didn't see you
specifically I saw your people I saw
them down there they were down there
they were uh looking exactly like
this this was you this was your gig well
listen so there's a bigger conversation
here which is and this is a little bit
in the bassoon King I talk about my
spiritual journey and I talk about
spirituality more in the new book Soul
boom but I grew up a member of the bahai
faith it's a very beautiful Faith it's
all about love and unity and peace
and I jettisoned that like so many of us
do when you're 20 years old you move to
the big city or maybe you go in the
military or whatever you're college or
you go get a job somewhere whatever your
life Journey wherever it takes you and I
wanted nothing to do with spirituality I
don't wanted nothing to do with God and
morality and didn't want to think about
that thing I just wanted to live a what
I thought of like a Bohemian lifestyle
which is party go crazy make art like
you know live life to the extreme in
that in that sense and you know and and
that was good you know we talked about
these hilarious times in the in the
acting company and other theater that I
did and you know and then I got more and
more uh dependent on drugs and alcohol I
really realize now that I was using them
to medicate my anxiety so I wasn't I was
occasionally like a fall down drunk but
I wasn't like one of those guys that
every time they drink they pass out in
their own vomit or something like that
but I was
you know year after a year using a lot
of drugs and alcohol to just cope and
just get by in my daily life and I was
really unhappy I was really miserable
and this started a journey for me um
which was a a spiritual one where I was
kind of like this and and I realize now
that I was having a lot of mental health
issues at the time like I would have
anxiety attacks I was depressed a lot um
I was experiencing extreme loneliness um
it didn't make sense to me I was living
my dream we've we've been through my
life story here I am living New York
City I'm working as an actor and from
Suburban Seattle this loser D and D kid
this is incredible and yet I was deeply
deeply unhappy and why am I so unhappy
and why am I filled with so much anxiety
and that's what kind of led me to
examine God and
spirituality um as a possible path
toward recovery I didn't at that point
didn't go into 12-step programs but I
was I started to really dig deep into
God and the meaning of life and you know
why we're here because at that time
there weren't podcasts to where you
could go listen to you know you or or
Rich role or someone that's going to
make you like really think and learn
huberman and you know learn about how
this stuff works and there weren't that
many resources you know in the in the
early 90s at this point Point around
this stuff no one did therapy therapy
was for really rich people you know and
I certainly didn't have money for
therapy and uh you know you couldn't
call it like better help or something
like that so that this is the only thing
I knew to do from my childhood was like
read about God and I read the Bible I
read the Quran I read uh the I was a big
reader I read uh the the Buddha you know
the original works of the Buddha the
Bhagavad Gita and
started really thinking like well maybe
because I threw everything to do out
with religion and God and faith and
spirituality out the window maybe I
threw the baby out with the bath water
and you know maybe this stuff could
actually help me so it was like it was
the best of times it was the worst of
times like I wouldn't trade it for the
world I had an amazing time had you know
this chocol block with crazy Adventures
of New York and and and partying and and
it was it was fun and great until it
wasn't any anymore and I was pretty
unhappy and was trying to make my
relationship work with now my wife we've
been together for 30 years and uh you
know and that's what set me on this
spiritual journey and and interest in in
spiritual topics so that's one of the
threads that runs through bassoon King
that I really dive into in in Soul boom
yeah yeah no doubt um you just mentioned
your wife so you at some point you take
leave or I don't know what you call it
in the civilian world you go on vacation
I guess you go on vacation and you go to
Washington and you had you knew her but
you look her up in the White Pages which
was very very
romantic and she's in there yeah and so
you call her yeah isn't it weird you
used to have to like find a person's
phone number and she tells a story
really funny her and her roommate were
so broke they were like trying to decide
like should we pay the extra 75 cents a
month or whatever it is to have your
name listed in the way pages and they're
like yes we're going to make that
investment who knows someone might need
to look us up and call us one of these
times so there she was Holly reinhorn I
remember she was hot and cool and uh
edgy and and wonderful and gave her a
call and got together and you were kind
of like just kind of the Romantic dream
for her I mean you're like this actor
guy living in New York City I moved to
New York I went to acting school was
like professional actor hell yeah yeah
that was
just you rolled in there you rolled in
there big time it all goes back to that
first drama class that first drama class
yeah and and then she ends up moving
back to New York with you it's like a
year later um you get it sounds like you
got like the sickest apartment ever in
Brooklyn like 13 foot ceilings like this
really it's dirt well we locked into
this $800 a month apartment that was
insane yeah it was insane we had huge
parties there you was great you roll
into this uh chapter in the book The the
the chapter title is I bombed on
Broadway which is you know uh doesn't
sound very good but it kind of set you
in the right motion and part of this you
know you you just kind of talked about
this here you were a professional actor
yet you weren't happy at the time right
you just not happy which is crazy to
think about um there I was not happy in
Brooklyn and I wasn't exactly sure why I
would wake up in the middle of night
deeply deeply sad alienated disconnected
then I would kick myself why are you
feeling this way I mean look what what
amazing woman you have asleep beside you
think of all the incredible theater
you're doing you have everything you
ever wanted including a kickass van we
haven't even talked about your van yet
but you had a kickass van your dream has
come true and yet you're still not happy
jerk face and fast forward a little bit
I thought I had started sneaking up I
had a thought that started sneaking up
around me at this time perhaps the
reason I'm not happy is I don't have
meaning I don't have purpose started
asking my friends about God this is kind
of where what you were just talking
about you go through this like you said
it's a kind of what you remembered from
your childhood and like there's got to
be something there let's start digging
and you start that's what you do you
start
digging and um as you're digging through
that you have a good story about Daryl
strawberry you asked D Daryl strawberry
if what is the uh W wak tanka which is
the Native American Spirit and you
prayed a wonan Tonka during this
baseball game yeah for darl strawberry
to get a home run so you win so I I had
I really struggled with the idea of God
like I was really struggling with like
God daddy God I call him Sky Daddy and
soul boom like this idea of this man
patriarchal man with a big beard looking
down at us all and judging us and I just
really struggled with that I'm like I'm
trying to figure it out and I was
reading a lot of Native American
spirituality at the time and
and the lotas Su word for God is
wakantanka which literally translates to
the great
mystery and it's the God of Nature and
the seasons and Beyond time and space
and you can only know this God kind of
through nature and um through the wind
and through the Sun and um and I was
like a that's really interesting so I
was talking to my friend about it's like
I don't believe in God but I believe in
wakantanka
so he's like prove it and I was like
okay the Mets were down bottom of the
9th Daryl strawberry was up and I was
like let's try it and I literally went
oh
wakantanka uh grandfather Spirit great
mystery if you exist please help us and
have Daryl strawberry Help win this game
if you show show
yourself I am not
turn to the
TV over the field walkoff home run ends
the game yeah and me and my friend Phil
who's one of my best friends we still I
was just talking to him earlier we were
just like yo
whoa but it it wasn't enough to convince
Phil he's still an atheist but uhhuh
that was as silly and stupid as that
sounds I was
like okay gotta keep going go down this
path let's see where this goes um
meanwhile
you you get this role you get a you get
a lead role in a in a Broadway show and
you say this about the role in the
months and weeks leading up to the
rehearsals I grew increasingly nervous
the pressure was Building inside I felt
an immediate stress mounting within me
about how would need to really shine in
this role a stressful voice in my head
kept prodding this play could give me a
better agent this role could land me a
Tony nomination this is my chance to get
an amazing New York Times review the
pressure continued to increase and build
through the rehearsals and eventual
performances until you you guessed it I
totally sucked in the role I bombed on
Broadway but and isn't it funny how life
works it turned out to be one of the
best experiences of my life in
rehearsals I was stiff and disconnected
I had for some weird reason decided
exactly how to play the role in my head
all my choices were pred decided they
were also broad fakey and strangely
puppet-like I could feel myself throwing
out all my training and rehearsed the
play by doing strained line reading
after strained line reading I knew I was
sucking and I didn't know what to do I
could tell internally and also from the
quizzical almost sad looks I was getting
from the rest of the cast Joe pulled me
aside after a couple weeks and spoke to
me quite seriously about his concerns
with me in this role he urged me to
relax and just explore and play and have
fun in the Pro in the rehearsal process
but Tri as I might I just couldn't I was
in a gigantic pressurized acting rut and
I couldn't escape all of a sudden we
were getting close to having an audience
I freaked I began waking up in the
middle of the night shaking and sweating
I was terrified I knew that I was about
to suck in my first big Big Show holiday
was in Iowa at the time I spent many
tearful hours in the middle of the night
with her on the phone as she consulted
and counseled me that's when the prayers
started when all fails sometimes you
just get on your knees and ask for help
and I did over and over again I reached
out for assistance from wonan Tonka God
creator whatever I was stuck I was lost
and terrified I literally didn't know
what else to do the prayers didn't make
me a brilliant actor all the sudden but
I do believe they were a factor in a
transformation I made as an artist and
as a per person at this pivotal juncture
I started to understand that I had been
doing the role for all the wrong reasons
to impress people to gain accolades to
gain Fame I was looking outside myself
trying to be something I wasn't for
others London Assurance that's the name
of the play you were in broke me open
like an egg I didn't want to be that
kind of fakey artist anymore performing
out of obligation needing neediness and
a desperate need to be liked I knew that
I ultimately needed to be myself and
screw whatever other people thought of
me I felt this newfound commitment to
freedom in my bones and it was a
revelation after this Broadway Fiasco I
learned how to relax and breathe and
play I embraced the natural nerdy
oddness that was me I was never going to
be the same some formal idea of a
classical actor man beloved by casting
directors in the New York Times and
rocking an ascot as the previews went
along I did see some eventual
Improvement I was able to relax a bit
here and there and get a few occasional
laughs in the role was I good no but at
least I wasn't completely horrible I got
almost I got mostly pour to middling
reviews but at least I didn't get Rak
over the coals more important after the
show closed I was filled with as much
great with a much greater purpose and
inspiration in my life and
work
yeah keep going read the rest of the
book there's only like 170 more
pages uh that's kind of this this is
this had a huge impact on you I mean
obviously this is like a this this is a
story that I tell young people a lot
when I speak at colleges and it and it's
something you've covered on your pod a
lot but it's like what we learn from
failure you know and and how important
failure is in making us who we are and
we kind of in modern society it's like
failure is a weakness and it's bad and
you're wrong and you should never fail
but by stucking in this Broadway
play and kind of going through the fire
you know I was on the Anvil being
pounded because it you know I mean
you've been in firefights with mortars
dropping on your head I'm not comparing
it to that but I will say that when you
your longing is to be an actor and
you're doing your first lead on Broadway
and you're doing eight shows a week for
four or five months and then you suck
and you have to go in every single day
and perform and you know you're not good
and you know the audience is
like um it's really painful and then it
it caused a lot of soul searching and
like I was trying to be Mr actor man of
New York to get the New York Times
review and like get some kind of
accolades or a Tony nomination and I was
doing it for the wrong reasons and
trying to be someone or something that
I'm I'm inherently not and after I
sobbed and talked to Holly on the phone
after I was praying on my knees after I
was like I just went through the ringer
on this thing I was like that I'm
never doing that again I'm never going
through that again I'm GNA bring exactly
who I am to the roles that I play and if
they don't like it screw them I have to
be myself this helped me find my
authentic voice as an actor and as a
human being and I'm so grateful for one
of the most painful four to five months
of my life I've ever gone through I'm
grateful for it because on that on that
Forge again no mortars dropping on my
head but on that particular Forge it
showed me a path so my failure my
struggle my pain forged me into someone
that could eventually play Dwight on the
office I never would have played Dwight
on the office if I had not bombed on
Broadway so what I thought was like the
biggest failure of my life actually
turned into the greatest success in my
life so embracing roles like Dwight um
uh where I could just draw on my own
natural quirkiness and I and come up
with my own vision of how to play the
character I wasn't when I started Dwight
I wasn't thinking about mey Awards or
money or stardom or any of that stuff um
that showed me the way so it's it's a
really important lesson for for Young
Folks especially to learn some sometimes
it's kind of like you talk to young
people and like I'm failing I'm
struggling I'm hurting
good when we were talking earlier about
giving your giving a 100% right and you
you were saying hey you've got to give
yourself a
100% to acting or writing or whatever it
is you're going to
do and I I've had conversations with
people um about two things that are
somewhat similar to that but writing
books and doing a podcast right and
right now of course everybody has a
podcast right now and you can write
books really easily but when people
would talk to me about it they'd be like
I think I'm going to start a podcast or
I want to write a book that's the two
things that a lot of people have said to
me in the past 10 years or I guess it's
been seven years or whatever however
long I've been doing this stuff and one
thing that I tell them is you you've got
to do it because you want to do it like
even even this
podcast if if we were to if someone said
hey uh or if I said hey I'm going to I'm
going to do a podcast here's what the
podcast is going to be about we're going
to make it three four or five hours long
we're going to talk about war
death genocide we're going to talk about
the most horrible subject it's going to
be me I'm going to be reading from old
books that are out of print and that's
what we're going to do there's no one
that would have said oh that sounds like
it's going to be a hit that sounds like
a yeah sign me up you've got but I I did
it and the path that we went down was
just cuz this is what I'm into this is
what I like this is what I'm interested
in same thing with books if you're going
to write a book and your goal of the
book is to be a New York Times
bestseller or your goal of the podcast
is to be the number one podcast you're
gonna be like rain Wilson in uh that
play trying really hard to get a good
review and it's like it doesn't that's
not what brings it you're looking
looking for something outside of
yourself for validation and for
happiness as opposed to an inner
motivation and you do you do you know
there's a lot of people that that write
to me and talk to me about the exact
same thing and they want to start a
podcast because they want
the they want the Accutron of the
successful podcast they want like
accolades and people looking up to them
and they want to be invited on other
podcasts and they want to be published
and they want to be get a speaking gig
lecture ing gigs at colleges or whatever
it is and yeah you got to find your
authentic voice which you have done
masterfully and I was able to do as an
actor and it gave me some success uh
because I jettisoned all of that
and I was just like I'm gonna play weird
up roles and this is who I am and
if you don't like it that's fine you
don't have to watch screw you and it's
the same way today with social media and
you know with podcast in and voicing
your opinion and stuff like that it's
like I got to be me this is who I am
this what I think and I get a lot of
backlash sometimes and it's all right
that's fine you can you can pull your
hair out and threaten to kill me on
YouTube it's all great it's all fine I
don't give a I really don't I've
just passed that so uh I do want to be
part of a much larger conversation of
how do we make ourselves better people
and how do we make the world a better
place let's just engage in that
conversation these These are good
conversations yeah yeah and have fun
doing
it um so now you get this I'm going to
fast forward a little bit timeline wise
the next section that I'm going to go to
is welcome to Los Angeles uh and I had
to throw this in there Hollywood for the
seven of you that don't know is not
anything like you think it is from the
association with that famous grandiose
name there's nothing tinsle or fabulous
or razzled dazzly about that place this
was especially true in 1999 busy and yet
somehow completely destitute it was
popular populated with drug addicts
strippers schizophrenics and
scientologists besides a wax museum some
sickly palm trees and occasional
confused Dutch tourist and the stars on
Hollywood Boulevard there was nothing
there to let you know that there was a
show business industry in its history or
in the vicinity but if you wanted
marijuana wigs a taco or a taco it was
definitely the place to
be it is weird for people that haven't
been to California and Hollywood
it's really like you you wouldn't know
that there's anything there yeah it's
different now there's kind of more Glitz
there's the mall there and some right
it's it's kind of a little better you
know but you could still buy a wig and a
taco and and any drug you want probably
so yeah and you can still join
Scientology readily if you want to yeah
oh yeah you can walk right in they' be
glad to have you but uh yeah it's so
funny cuz all the all the the magic gets
made on the sound stages is in the
studios but there's nothing in Hollywood
that has to do with that and even then
you go into a studio and it just just
looks like this it's just like these
rooms and there's a couple cameras and
you know some trailers and some dollies
and a bunch of cables and lying around
it's nothing really that fabulous and
you had come out um you guys had had
made a show what is it new new boen the
new boen yeah we did a me and my friends
uh did a clown comedy sketch comedy
weird surreal comedy piece that we had
created in New York and had done pretty
well in New York and we brought it out
to LA and this was David C was David uh
costable yeah he's on billions and he
was on Breaking Bad yeah he was I was in
billions with him no kidding yes that's
awesome what a freaking good dude that
whole place was I it was interesting it
was the first time I ever did anything
like that yeah and so I didn't really
know what was going on and I didn't know
how popular billions was and so I got
hooked up Tim Ferris is a friend of mine
and they asked him if I would want to be
on it like Tim and I were on the same
episode anyways I like sounds cool
whatever I was going to New York and I
went out there and actually I showed up
and David was like he he he was like
super cool but he he's like I showed up
and I'm like oh hi and he's like welcome
to billions as if like and I was kind of
like well that's kind of weird you know
I was like that's strange cuz I had only
watched like on my flight to New York I
watched the first like three episodes so
I really didn't know what was going on
and I didn't know how freaking good that
show was uh then I was Hook Line and
Sinker and I've I've um watched the
whole thing but yeah I was that was
another thing like I'm with those guys
and these guys are studying lines like
I'm sitting there and that's the other
freaking jacked up thing so they I had
to got a script right and I kind of
thought like well you don't actually
like read the script or whatever like in
a show you just kind of make up and
so I hadn't memorized the I don't know
how many lines I had but however many
lines I had I didn't memorize any of I
thought I was going to be me and just
talk because I was literally myself
right yeah so I get there and now I'm
watching what's going on with the as
they're filming other sections and I was
and like oh they do the same thing
over and over again over and over and
over again like 20 times and I was like
holy I've got to do the same thing
over and over again I'm totally AIT I'm
like sitting there trying to memorize my
nine lines or whatever it was yeah uh
but what a good what a great dude
actually the everyone there was awesome
um Brian coppelman and Dave LaVine have
been just they were just super cool and
still super cool uh but yeah and then
David from when he was in Breaking Bad
and The Whole Nine Yards yeah yeah he's
he's one of my oldest dearest friends
and it it's great he's had a great
career and we started doing these
weird sketch comedy clown characters
it's hard to describe what it was but
that's what brought us to La so yeah cuz
like your director or something was
there uh your our producer had moved
there to work in TV and film and he
brought us out and we did the stage play
bunch of different theaters and we got a
TV deal at Fox and um you know just
started getting the whole TV and film
thing going and meanwhile you do five
auditions you eventually get Almost
Famous mhm great San Diego movie by the
way uh Galaxy Quest that my first two
movies The
Expendables that wasn't the not the
movie you're thinking of it was a
different show called The Expendable uh
and you say suddenly I thought I had
this whole La thing figured out I rolled
into town and gotten a pilot a couple of
film rolls without a single hitch we set
up the new bozena at Fox do a pilot
presentation and made more money in a
couple months and in all the previous
years combined I was in and feeling like
a maid man holiday and I decided to
settle down in LA and make a go of it
she would finish her book of short
stories I would be an actor who could
actually pay the bills then within a few
months the new bosena got rejected by
Fox and I was unemployed for a full
year Showbiz eventually do House of
thousand corpses for Rob Zombie yes yeah
20th anniversary just passed hell yeah
20th anniversary uh he did the movie
America sweethearts CSI Law and Order
couple
pilots and cancelled shows that no one
ever heard of to pay the bills and
continue to build my career
you get you get you're one of the final
actors uh for Arrested Development to
play to play job yeah damnn yeah yeah
you say this about that after several
auditions I was once again being tested
for the project there were two final
scenes that we jobes would be doing
along the side the rest of the family
who had already been cast in one scene
there were one or two lines and and in
the other scene there were a couple of
pages of really funny dialogue and a
great chance to show off what you could
do with the character we all filed in
one at a time to show the head of fox
the first short scene the other jobes
went in to do the second bigger scene I
waited nervously going over my lines and
bits and preparation I waited and waited
and waited I was sitting all alone in
the waiting room and after 10 or 15
minutes I wandered out of the hallway
everyone had left I mean everyone actors
casting agents Fox Executives janitors
everyone I finally saw a casting
assistant cleaning up in a corner and
asked what was going on I guess they saw
they needed to see from you she chirped
merrily and I slunk away embarrassed and
miserable only having only auditioned
with two lines for the best comic role
I'd ever read yeah that was uh I still
that just kind of staggers me that there
were like three of us the other one was
uh Michael um oh what's his name from
succession who plays Connor the older
brother Michael root Michael R Rudd I'm
forgetting his name a brilliant actor a
brilliant actor who's on succession he
was um and it was me him and will
Arnette who was obviously brilliant and
uh yeah do the first little scene and
they're like okay go wait over here and
we'll call you back in for your next
scene and they just B and I wait and I
wait and I wait I'm going over my lines
and wait and I wait and I wait it's like
and a half an hour later everyone's gone
and no one no one thought to go over
this how Hollywood Works no one thought
just like the common decency to just be
like rain thanks so much they're not
going to see you for the next scene they
saw what they need needed and they're
going to go in a different direction
thank you so much for coming in like no
one could just do that and it was it was
humiliating it was it was pretty
humiliating but it it it's part for the
course you just keep going and uh will
Arnette was great for that and I'm
grateful I didn't get cast in that
because that wouldn't have played Dwight
if I had been cast on a rest of
development he's had a great career I've
had a great career and uh it all works
out in the end I was up in La uh talking
to a company but wherever I was talking
there was an audition going on uhhuh for
something and there was
500 uh teenage girls between the ages of
like 11 and 14 lined up around the block
it's with with their holding their pages
and stuff yeah it was like crazy one of
my friends Works in LA and he like runs
movies and shows and stuff and he says
it's the worst thing like every person
that walks in that room you are holding
their dream right and you are just
holding their dream and they seem like
the nicest and they're good for the role
but there's someone that's just a little
bit better and you just take their dream
and just throw it away and you don't
even have time like what you're saying
he's like yeah I mean you had three
people but when there's 500 people in
the line it's like oh here's your dream
oh smash it next he said it's he hates
it he wasn't do it anymore he has a
casting director and he just like won't
do it anymore because it's heartbreaking
yeah yeah it's brutal process but you
one thing you realize when you're uh
because I've been on the other side
casting on stuff that I've produced or I
was starring in or whatever and you
especially when you see people in the
room or now it's mostly on tape you see
kind of on the cloud they upload their
auditions or whatever but you know in
like 30 seconds whether they're right or
not and it's nothing to do with them
it's nothing even to do with their
talent or anything like like you just
see them and their Vibe it's all a Vibe
thing their Vibe and how they're doing
the the lines and stuff
like yeah and yeah so that's what my
buddy said like someone would walk in
and he not even 30 seconds he looks at
the person like they can't play this
role but he's like you've got to let
them do their thing they've worked for
hours or days on it and yeah it's tough
freaking a awful by the way your son was
born 2004 this is in this time frame um
you got the harrowing story of the birth
of your son in the book so get the book
um you end up in this in this show six
feet on under and
um that as you mentioned eventually
leads to chapter
14 Dwight K sh assistant to the regional
manager um you say I was the very first
person to audition for the office
literally our incredible casting
director Allison Jones who casts all of
Jud Appo and Paul fe's movies as well as
vep and a myriad of other brilliant
comedies had recently gotten to know me
as an actor and I was starting to get
get some notice because my role on 6
Feet Under she called me into audition
for both Michael and Dwight and I was
excited beyond words as I led the
project so much I sat in the waiting
room clutching my pages literally more
eager for this audition than any of the
hundreds I had been on in the past yeah
and that's just because you knew the the
story I knew the British office I had
seen it early on I thought it was
amazing and um everyone was like oh
they're going to ruin it and they can
never make an American version and
everyone was on it especially
British people but um I was like well
why why not you know and I still am like
there's still people that are kind of
like I look the British better it's like
okay you can watch all 12 of the British
series over and over again for the rest
of your life every single day no one's
taking that away from you meanwhile we
went and made 200 episodes of a of a
different kind of version and it needed
be different CU they're British has
subsidized television they have no
commercials so they getting literally
government grants they can do much
shorter Seasons we've got to do long
Seasons with commercial breaks we have
shorter episodes anyways the list goes
on and on but I was a huge fan of the
British show and oh man I was I was so
excited and and it was one of those
things where you know wakan Tonka was
smiling on me you know like I knew from
the second I read Dwight I was like
that's my role I absolutely absolutely
know how to play this role and uh uh I
was like there's no one else that can do
this the way that I can so I did a
terrible audition for Michael I I went
in and just did Ricky jves I literally
was like so I'm uh you know I'm a
manager here and uh well uh you know
it's hard everyone nobody loves me and
like world's best boss and and it was it
was just really not right and then I
went in for for Dwight and I was like I
can undo drink my own
urine and you know and they were just
like yeah
okay this guy knows what he's doing but
it was but even then like I I really
killed the audition but the call backs
weren't for months later and the
callbacks
were this is back in the day they they
they spent so much time and energy and
money on the casting I mean it was
really they spent months on the casting
they saw everybody and it was a really
important project to NBC and then they
mixed and matched us over a course of a
weekend and they filmed us which hard so
that a test where like the the studio
Executives decide in a in a test a TV
test or Pilot test who they're going to
cast it wasn't like coming into a room
and Performing for a bunch of Executives
they just watched the tape which is a
much better way of doing it so I got
matched up with Bob
Odenkirk who was up for Michael he was
like it was between Bob Kirk and Steve
Carell wow two brilliant talents but Bob
was a little dark yeah he was a little
dark for the role yeah he could played
the British one maybe yeah yeah but he
you know God bless him he's had such a
great career he's such an amazing actor
and you know as soon as you saw Steve
Carell do it it was just
like I hadn't seen him act
before and they sent us into like
improvise with each other and I was like
laughing in the in the audition and um I
had never seen an actor like that before
or since I mean his his ability he's
just so faasil he can just improvise off
of anything and that's the that's the
amazing thing about I know I'm skipping
around here a lot but that's the amazing
thing about about Steve is like you talk
about learning lines like he would learn
his
lines but he's a kind of actor like you
could throw anything at him I did it
over 200 episodes and it would never
break him and he would never it couldn't
you couldn't throw him off you could not
he had done so much improv you could not
throw him off you know if you're doing a
scene and you're talking about how well
we better go to the Italian restaurant
on a lunch break and and you're like and
you just throw in a line
like you know I I really never loved my
mother and he would just be like Dwight
what are you talking about your mother
right now we got to get to that Italian
restaurant it wouldn't even like f he
would just take anything and weave it in
in and uh that was incredible to learn
from cuz I came from this Shakespeare
background right theater background and
memorizing lines and Performing and
stuff like that and Steve was all about
just like just Mercurial and just being
able to do to turn on a dime who's Greg
Daniels he's the showrunner he was the
main writer for our show kind of he he
shaped he took the English thing and
shaped it for the American audience and
he's kind of when they showrunner
basically means they make all the
decisions so
the casting the edits the cuts the the
the final scripts the budgets they're
really the big executive producer
overseeing the whole thing and and is
would you say he's the guy that like had
the vision
of because they were obviously putting a
lot of effort into this yeah is he the
guy that thought like hey this is going
to be if we do this right we got we got
a freaking gold mine here 100% yeah he
Greg Daniels is he doesn't get enough
credit for what he did but but he's very
meticulous and he really just had lists
of like here's what I love about the
British office and here's what is not
going to work for an American audience
and he really wanted more heart I don't
know if here's a good indicator of that
look at the difference in Michael Scott
from season one to season two so in
season one Steve himself was a little
overweight he would admit that and he
had they had Michael Scott like Ricky
slick his hair back is thinning a little
bit and like he was much more like just
unlikable just kind of like a greasy
used car salesman a little bit and and
they realize even though season one is
pretty brilliant and pretty freaking
funny um they realize like we need to
make Michael Scott more accessible
approachable because he's doing so
many more horrible things so they kind
of like did his hair better and they
dressed him a little better they lit it
a little nicer just look at the
difference even in the lighting and they
made they gave him a little more heart
just a just a little bit more not all of
a sudden he's hugging puppies right but
in fact they say that on TV like if
you've got an unlikable character then
you've got to show them early on being
really nice to an animal and then the
audience will like them and then they
can forgive all the dastardly things
they do but but it wasn't like that with
Michael Scott but they just gave him a
little more heart and a little more
warmth and you felt for him a little bit
you realized like oh he's kind of a lost
pupp dog himself but in season one he
was a little it was a little more like
the British show um but so Greg Daniels
is the one making those decisions and
going you know and being really sure
that and he said early on he said listen
because at the time I don't know if you
remember this but American com
television comedy 2005 was not very good
putting Seinfeld and Friends aside which
were brilliant there were a there was
was a lot of crappy shows out there um I
love Everybody Loves Raymond was great
there were there were some Classics and
then a sea of crap and so he's like you
know if we can take the world of comedy
and just turn it it's like a comedy is
like an ocean liner we can turn it one
degree in the right direction we can
influence comedy in the right way and
that's that's what the office did it
didn't do one degree it did like five
degrees and made comedy a lot smarter
but it was so revolutionary what we
doing at the time single camera poorly
lit like fluorescent lights really
average to
unattractive characters and even like
Jim and Pam like like Jenna and JN are
are are really good-look but they're not
like models right they're just they're
real people they're real people who are
kind of goodlook on the good-look side
of things and at the time they were
casting all these like models and these
sitcoms and stuff and that wasn't
working out so well so the fact that
it's real people handheld like shaky
camera there were a lot of um things
that really broke and we almost got
canceled so many times I mean we did not
do well we got terrible reviews go
Google the early reviews of the office
they were terrible like oh not as good
as the English office and there some
haters on that English off God oh my God
it just never it just never it still
doesn't end it's still it's just just
incredible well British people have a
different sense of humor like I said I'm
married to a Brit so I I get some of
that English humor but Americans don't
have that same sense of humor right we
needed the American office yeah and we
needed it bad yeah like the British
office if you're an American watching it
you're depressed you can very well end
up depressed you're like oh this is this
doesn't make me feel good it's funny but
I'm like laughing at these people and I
feel guilty about it when I'm done it's
like not a feeling it's pretty cynical
yeah yeah and and the American office is
to it's American yeah well and I think
the interesting thing is about the
office which no one saw coming by the
way was when it started to stream on
Netflix in
2016 17 and 18 I don't know I don't even
know when it started someone should
Google that get on that yes um never
been called sir before uh the uh um and
all of a sudden you had and this
probably applies to your kids you had
teenagers watching the show over and
over and over again and all of a sudden
I was meeting 14-year-olds who had seen
the entirety of the office like seven
times and this was way but now now
they've seen it like 70 times that's my
that's my kids 100% they all of them
they just leave it on but I think that
little bit of heart that Greg Daniels
the reality and the heart that Greg
Daniels put in every episode and he
always wanted he said listen that the
show's got to be just 85 90% just comedy
but just that 10 to 15% of reality and
heart that we that we sprinkle in will
go a super long way I remember that even
as a kid watching MASH I remember what
because I was always interested in war
and I'd get to watch the show and it was
like funny and then every once in a
while you'd be like oh like I'm a kid
and I'd be like oh these guys are
at War I remember this one scene Alan
alos towards the end of the series Alan
Al is talking about like this woman he's
like oh she she had this chicken and was
chicken was making noise and they were
on this bus and blah blah blah blah and
she killed the chicken and you know and
then you find out that she actually
killed her kid to get the kid to be
quiet and I I me I remember watching
that as little kid so it was this funny
show but then it would have these
impactful moments and the office
definitely had plenty of those impactful
moments for sure you got this one
section in here where you talk about
Greg Daniels kind of
early on pulls you aside and says like
he told me in a very diplomatic way he
loved my acting during the improves and
you liked my acting much less during the
scripted scenes it's true it's true
that's not and I had already gotten the
part and I was
like God and then you go and watch the
videos and you're like oh I see it yeah
so I convinced the one producer who had
a management company and I had a manager
at the same company and I was like you
need to let me watch the auditions he's
like I can't like just let me I just
need to see what I did that what Greg is
talking about because we hadn't started
shooting yet we would been doing table
reads and just rehearsing and stuff like
that so I got to go and watch all of my
auditions wait so the guy you talked the
guy into it yes so he he showed he had
just on his little like laptop or
whatever and I got to watch my
auditions and I was just like zoned in I
was like f
and like there's scenes that were
scripted where I had my you know my
lines and then there were scenes where
they said you know you and John just
have an argument about getting coffee
ready go and I would look at the and I
saw it and I saw what he and it was like
and it was still a little bit of that
theater actory kind of thing where I
kind of like would do a a line reading
or I'd make a line a certain way or I'd
decide kind of how a line should sound
or something and you know I wasn't bad
it just was a little
more presentational I don't know how
else to put it but the Improv stuff was
just much more real it's just talking
and shooting the and and being
weird and in a real natural way and I
was like and it really it was like I'm
so glad he brought that up I'm like oh
thank God good this is good so then I
just made the scripted stuff just sound
more like impra stuff and then I'd
improvise off the scripted stuff and uh
and ended up working working out
great you say this after we were all
cast on the show me Steve John and Jenna
went out for lunch at a non-descript
little sandwich place down the street
from the studio we had a conversation
that grandiose as it may sound is etched
into all of our minds we giddily discuss
the very real possibility that this show
could go on for eight years and that
would change the course of our lives and
how these parts we were about to
undertake would most likely be our most
defining roles just think about what
we're getting into the journey we're
about to go on could be amazing I
remember saying I remember Steve who was
just coming off of doing Anchor Man and
The 40-Year-Old Virgin saying all of the
role of all the roles I'll end up doing
in films I may shoot I believe that
Michael Scott may be the role I'll
always be most known for it was one of
those moments when Destiny when our
destiny was seen with complete Clarity
like a country road from a hot air
balloon all while eating a tuna sandwich
but the weird thing is like you so you
guys saw that the magic you guys saw
some of that magic we were like early on
we like this could really be
something this could really be something
you know I me we had no idea that I mean
it exceeded even that I mean it's become
this cultural phenomenon I walk into
Target and like my face is on a mug and
a hot plate and a and an apron and shoes
and like we have we have a freaking lot
of office merch at my house oh yeah we
got freaking pajamas with your head on
it and like that um but the weird
thing is it didn't come out like you
just mentioned it didn't come out of the
gate that strong not as a matter of fact
it wasn't it was like getting picked up
ones and twozies right like yeah so the
second season the first season was only
six episodes and they kind of back
doored Us in and then and it really was
only because the success of The
40-Year-Old Virgin and they were like
hey you've got a movie star on this show
like but like yeah but it's so weird
these were the the Jeff Zucker years it
was not a good time at NBC they made a
lot of colossal errors and um and so
they were like okay well we'll we'll
order five more episodes and then we did
and then like well we can afford two
more and then well one more and then and
then it just started
to and that second season started to uh
take off and then this thing happened
with iTunes yeah which holy I didn't
recognize this so the first IP what do
they call it an iPod came out but it had
video on it yeah vers video iPod came
out in 2005 and they put what the first
season of the office or the second
season they put the
office Christmas episode preloaded onto
every video iPod so every rich kid in
the
country you know whose parents could
afford a $200 or $300 video iPod player
MP3 player he got it and he had an
Office episode on there and they were
watching it and they're Like These Guys
these kids are like and that was our was
the weirdest thing too is like here's
we're doing a show about people working
in an office we thought the audience
would be people that had worked in
offices and our biggest audiences were
high school and college kids which
advertisers Love by the way so yeah that
that was another thing that kind of
40-year-old so many things had to happen
in the right way for us to have the run
that we had and that was another one of
them
and then it goes like this then all of a
sudden NBC put a giant billboard of us
in front of their Burbank offices
someone on the crew had taken a photo of
that billboard while driving past and I
John jenet and Steve huddled around
looking at it laughing ecstatically
after about a 100 elated high fives we
settled back down to do the scene at
hand giggling secretly a photo that that
billboard was hung on the wall just
outside of our set and stayed there for
the duration of the show we knew then we
were going to be on the air for a long
long time we were off and
running so that's it you see the
billboard then you made it you know
people don't understand about acting is
um to get on a TV show as an actor in
any capacity is really really hard to do
it's you even if you're really talented
and trained you've got to have
representation you've got to get the
right things just to get a single role
if you get a a a recurring role on a TV
show that's even harder if you get a
pilot and that pilot gets picked up to
if you get a pilot it's so hard to do
and it's a miracle that you get a pilot
and that pilot gets picked up to series
that's a triple miracle and if the
series gets picked up and does multiple
Seasons That's a quadruple miracle and
then if it has a full run like N9 10
year run then if it win wins Awards then
if it lasts 10 20 years after you
started it like I mean it's like hitting
the jackpot over and over and over again
it's like hitting the roulette wheel I
put 20 black boom hit it again hit it
hit it hit it hit it that's what it's
like to do the office so you know I'm
just even today like 10 years after we
have finished our last episode like I'm
just in awe of what we were able to do
I'm so grateful for the the role the
experience I mean it was it was it was
it was a miracle and with with one of
the greatest like ensembles ever
assembled I mean the amount of talent in
that room was just Preposterous and
there's got to be some level I'm
guessing of like the Beatles right The
Beatles were only the Beatles because of
that group of people and like when they
all split off and they doing their own
thing yeah they made some stuff blah
blah but no one really cares about John
Lennon or even Paul McCartney or like
they don't care about what they did solo
really it's about the Beatles yeah same
thing with well with Black Sabbath right
you had Black Sabbath then you had
Aussie break off Tony like I love those
guys but it's about Black Sabbath
there's something special about that
chemistry lead Zeppelin same thing right
you got lead
Zeppelin When lead Zeppelin is lead
Zeppelin and once you
once uh John bonam dies it it's just not
going to be the same so there's that
Miracle as well that you get this group
of people and if it had been a different
you know Michael Scott or a different
Dwight or a different gim or a different
Pam it might have just been just a
little bit of chemistry and then you
don't get what you get yeah and maybe we
would have done those six episodes have
been canell or canceled halfway through
the second season if we didn't have that
you know if Bob Odenkirk had been cast
and Brilliant Bob odenkirk's one of
America's best actor writer directors
brilliant nothing against him at all but
if they had gone in that direction you
know uh who knows you know well he's
also highly present in my house as you
know Saul yeah yeah very highly present
in my house okay so I guess we would
have been winning possibly either way or
maybe losing on both fronts well he
found a better he found a better outlet
for his acting and uh you know better
call SA Universe well that's what you
were saying earlier
like when PE like you're meant for that
role like he's meant for that role it's
hard to picture someone else pulling it
off yeah it's hard to picture someone
else pulling off the way it's hard to
picture some and I guess now we're kind
of all just it is what it is we that's
just the way it is but if you throw
someone else in there it's just a mess
could have been a mess yeah yeah you got
nominated for three Emmy Awards MH mhm
how' that how'd that work out I didn't
it didn't work out very well brutal I
lost two two of them to Jeremy
Piven who's Jeremy Piven he was on
Entourage he played Ari on Entourage
yeah what the agent on Entourage so is
that the leading role no it was the
supporting best comic supporting role
okay so you lost to him twice yeah have
you ever sent him hate mail
secretly um okay we can edit this part
out no com
I didn't send him hate mail per
se but he received some mysterious
packages in the mail check I want to I
want to break into his house and steal
one of those one of those emies he
should just give me one of them I know
he's got two after yeah he did great and
and Ari that was great just give me one
scratch it
out be easy yeah uh you got a whole
section in here random office memories
just go people go get the book uh
freaking hilarious stuff I'm not GNA try
and do it justice and by the way you
read the audio book too so I obviously
suck at reading you but I just did it
for this podcast that's the way I'm
doing it anyways get the audio book if
you don't want to get the book book
because you're too lazy to read get the
audio book and you can hear all these
stories um from rain
himself chapter 16 Soul
pancakes after some long consultations
and soul search with some spiritual
philosopher friends of mine co-founders
Joshua homnick and Devin gundry we
decided to create a destination for the
web for people interested in exploring
big ideas through the portals of
philosophy creativity and
spirituality we wanted our Endeavor to
be a successful business venture and not
a nonprofit because we felt there was a
large young audience out there that was
longing for positive content and you
talk about in the book here
about it's just at this time there
what's on the web is just a bunch of
freaking negativity and you guys want to
do something positive and cool yeah yeah
exactly hence Soul pancake how do that
go down yeah so you know I talked about
you know what a lottery win it is to um
be on a show that's going to be going
for a long time so all of a sudden for
the first time in my life I'm like 39
years old going into my 40s and I know
that I'm going to have 5 to 10 years of
like real paychecks
solid paychecks I've never had that
before remember this's a guy first 10
years of my career never made over 20
grand in a year in a year what do they
pay you for a pilot like when you're
doing the first what' you do six first
no 13 yeah so pilot fees vary for actors
I mean there can be a big star they
bring in for a pilot and they pay him a
million dollars to a pilot but you
weren't a big star I was not at all so
it's somewhere between you know a per
episode rate for actor is somewhere
between 20 grand to 50 Grand an episode
you know kind of early on then you
renegotiate your contract and then you
start getting more you start getting
into the hundreds of thousands per
episode and stuff like that so this was
like exponential money for oh my God
yeah so what that did is well and I had
already bought a house cuz I we bought a
a crappy little house in vanise
California that was cost2 $60,000 little
1100 foot house where my son was born
and then and then we upgraded once the
office was was going but um the uh
there's a responsibility that I felt and
maybe this was my upbringing my faith
tradition I'm not quite sure I was like
hey I'm gonna all of a sudden I'm gonna
have this huge platform like I'm gonna
be this guy who's on this TV show people
know who he is I've got something to say
I felt a responsibility to try and do
something positive in the world I I
don't know why I you talk to other
people and they're like I just want to
have a nice life I'm not saying I'm some
Saint or something like that I'm not at
all um I'm a colossal screwup but uh I
was like what am I gonna do and that's
where Soul pancake came out of a long
series of discussions with some friends
about like what can we best do to make
the world a better place what's the
biggest need and what we went to was
like positive uplifting content for
young people that dealt with life's
biggest questions we were doing videos
on Mental Health stuff kind of before
anybody was and uplifting joyful videos
videos that asked probing questions I
had a uh an interview talk Series in my
back of my van called metaphysical
milkshake you know and we had Kid
President we had a lot of different
shows it was right at the time when
YouTube it was a lot of crap it was a
lot of like Kardashians and and um Auto
uh credit score stuff and porn and and
just the kind of fails remember like
fails were really big and um it was just
kind of the worst of Humanity on the web
like can we make something beautiful and
uplifting and important but not you know
it doesn't take itself too seriously so
we made this uh it started as a web
destination quickly morphed into U
making a vid digital Med media content
company mostly through you YouTube
channel and we had a YouTube channel
that pretty early on at two or three
million subscribers and and we made over
3,000 pieces of content um that uh was
very positive and uplifting very
sharable and we had a lot of brand
partnership deals and we took the
company we sold the company to a place
called participant media which is an
even bigger Media company and they had
it for a couple of years and then it
kind of like faded away but it was we
had a long good 10 12 year run with with
that and uh got over a billion video
views and um made the world a a slightly
better place uh so I'm really proud of
that work yeah and you you were doing
charity work in there as well um how do
you say that the thing that you started
in ha in Haiti it's called Le day Le day
Haiti yeah got it yeah we still work on
that and that's it was a really
interesting part of the book
um uh where they were asking these young
Haitian girls what's your favorite color
yeah and which is like the common
question for every seven-year-old kid in
America like oh what's your favorite
color that's just what you do and these
girls didn't even know what that meant
it was like the foreign question was
they were and these were older girls
teenage girls and it you it was very
clear that they had never been asked
this question before and if that's the
case you know how are they being seen or
how are they not being seen because we
asked one girl and and she was like a
deer in the headlights and she was like
blue and and they were like oh okay blue
great oh great and then what about you
what's your favorite color and just
like blue they all said blue because
they just like what's right what's the
right answer what's the wrong answer
they had never so we realized that um
and we we came in after the earthquake
my wife and I and we were working with
Shawn Penn and some uh in his uh refugee
camp that he set up he was doing amazing
work and we started doing these classes
for in the Arts and Literacy for
adolescent girls and we saw how
incredible uh what an incredible bonding
Community it created and the girls like
we left doing our workshops and they
still gathered and kept meeting and we
started doing the workshops and they
were so shy and self-effacing and
insecure and by the end of like our two
week
workshops they were like expressive and
sharing their poetry they had written
and their photographs they had taken and
the drama they were doing and we saw
like how powerful the Arts are for
creating Community healing trauma which
I'm sure you know from veterans work and
um
and uh you know opening the way to
seeing these girls for who they really
are and um I'm never foret get that we
were when we started doing this work
with
leay this girl was like you know at
first I didn't understand what you guys
were doing cuz other people come here
they give us shoes you know they give us
places to live they give us food said
but you you give us hope and that's
that's really what we're trying to do is
educate the whole girl we're working
with over 800 girls in 12 different
locations we have a Haitian staff of 40
and um uh very excited and proud to be a
a co-founder but it's really Haitian L
and run and we just support it and I I
myself out as as Dwight to raise
money and send it over to educate these
girls and uh it's funny because in a
couple weeks we're doing a dinner with
it's called the office dinner party so
it's me and Steve and Angela are having
dinner and you could buy raffle tickets
to win or the highest bidder to go to
this dinner and we've we've already
raised a massive amount of money just to
have dinner yeah uh so yeah I can see
where you'd raise a massive amount of
money to have dinner with you'd want in
on that dinner 100% yeah definitely be
there for that one uh I'm gonna fast
forward a little bit you you close out
this book um uh the basson king you
close out this book with a with a
section called 10 Things I know for
sure one the deepest happiness comes
from service to
others like
100% if you think you're being funny
you're not being funny this is a heads
up isn't it it's a real important things
it's not just think you're being funny
if you think you're being cool you're
not being cool you know what I'm saying
this this applies to a lot of things
that we try and do as humans well said
uh gratitude changes
everything Rome is the greatest city on
Earth yeah so you put that in there as a
thing you know for sure yep fair enough
need to spend some more time here in San
Diego no but no I I'm I've been to San
Diego I'm the worst I'm the worst person
San Diego I don't want to leave my house
like nothing I don't want to go to Rome
I don't want to go to anywhere I don't
want to go to Paris La I don't want to
go I definitely don't want to go to La
Oceanside Oceanside
perhaps uh you make a a uh little shout
for Rome there the opinions of other
people are not something to worry about
that's number five yeah that's a very
good thing to learn the earlier you
learn that the better off you're going
to be now is there a dichotomy here
where if I'm like I don't give a
what anybody says I'm going to freaking
Spike the punch or whatever whatever
thing you're going to do like there's a
certain point where if everyone's
telling you you're acting like an
sure that's something you might
want to pay attention to yeah I mean
that's common sense wisdom like you we
learn we're social creatures so we learn
like oh I keep when I greet people I
punch them in the balls but people don't
seem to like me very much H maybe I
should stop punching them in the balls
like we you know you learn that way but
my sponsor in 12 steps actually said
this and I I just thought it was the
simplest thing and it's so it's so
profound um he said like what other
people think of you is none of your
business what you think about other
people is all of your
business so it's always being mindful of
like how am I am I treating people am I
respecting them am I listening to them
am I taking them in am I filled with
resentment do I have a huge I know
people and they have like this
resentment list like oh he's an
I'll never talk to them like this and
that and that's easy it's like a big
cancerous tumor on their shoulder you
know it's hard to live your life with
all of that resentment like how how am I
feeling about other people am I keeping
that clean people are going to whatever
they're going to think about me it's
fine that's that's it's completely out
of my control I'm going to try and be my
authentic self and and bring myself
every occasion with as much authenticity
and integrity as possible and I don't
always succeed but that's what I'm going
to that's what I'm going to try and do
and that's that's what's in my
control number six Game of Thrones is
our greatest teacher a few things I've
learned from the greatest TV show in the
history of everything a get a wolf B get
a dragon C women should rule the
world D politics are a waste of breath
and time dude I'm not I'm not I haven't
watched it yet what are you doing with
yourself I know you say you never leave
the house I know so watch Game
of Thrones bro what the hell and my my
middle daughter who you met she's like
she's like says it's freaking awesome
yeah um the last
season but uh yeah but I don't know see
the weird thing is I mean there's like
kind of a thread here of Dungeons and
Dragons and like I couldn't get into
that and now and like Jason Gardner who
I told you about earlier who's like
full-on dungeon dragon kid he loved Game
of Thrones freaking Game of Thrones all
day yeah I mean but he's but it's about
it's not about spells and Dragons as
much as it's about politics and human
nature and like and power and it's it's
all it's a Game of Thrones it's
literally like a giant chess game a
little bit of magic here and there but
it's not like prancing elves and ws and
Harry Potter and stuff like that so wait
are you bashing Harry Potter right now
can I give you an unpopular opinion yeah
I think Harry Potter sucks okay we can
edit this out dude because I don't you I
know I'm gonna get I don't care the
opinions of other people I said
unpopular opinion it's funny I've gone
on podcasts before and I'm like okay
unpopular opinion and then I've laid out
my unpopular opinion and then people are
in the comments are like I can't believe
he said that blah that's so stupid it's
like yeah I said it's an unpopular
opinion I don't like Harry Potter I
don't like the books I don't like the
and I especially don't like the movies
how come it's endless and who cares and
it's poorly written and it's it's it
it's really really good for 12year olds
and all the adults that have read it
like 17 times I'm really sorry you need
to grow the up damn because it's
all about like I wonder if she likes me
and I I'll pick out a new wand and I
wonder if the girl in my spells and
potion class likes me it's like that's
great when you're 12 that's great when
you're as well and the movies are 4
hours long M and they just they they
look like a stupid CW Show and they make
me sick okay well I'm going to go ahead
and just tell you please when you get
done watching the comments from this go
to rule five which is the opinions of
other people I'm not something to worry
about any other sacred cows you want to
slay at this time I've got so many I got
I could I could get me started here's
one that that would be a good podcast by
the way what's that unpopular opinion
just bring on a guest just say you get
one unpopular opinion they be like I
don't like sushi or whatever it is and
just like go why you know whatever
whatever it is whatever it is I don't
like sushi but rule number seven rule
number seven this is for you Echo
Charles yes sir Sushi is about the fish
idiots yeah meaning all the SAU R and
stuff it's not the sauces it's not the
rolls and the crispy onions and the
fried dough and dressing it up with all
of that crazy Shenanigans it's about the
fish bro right you're with me I'm with
you want to get some sush after this the
answer is right you're not invited I
don't want to come anyway you can go
read your Harry Potter watch Harry
Potter actually I haven't read Harry
Potter and see anything that's magical
and fantasical fanal fanal yeah anything
that's that I have a hard time like just
getting into it that's just the way I
don't know all right like fair enough
once I saw the 19 sided dice I was like
yo this is too much for
me uh number eight my son is my Sensei
beautiful man learning from those kids
Number Nine Stories Make the World Go
Round very important thing for people to
understand you know it is we humans are
storytellers and the earliest evidences
of human kind of culture is the cave art
right and you think about shaman in the
cave by candlelight and people putting
their hands in like powdered dyes and
putting their handprint on the on the
cave walls and the shamans telling the
mythologies the stories of the hunt
singing the songs and and carrying those
stories on generation to generation like
humans need to gather like we're doing
right here and tell stories we do that
in a movie theater that's why we really
lost something by just having streaming
all the time I went to go see Mission
Impossible in the theater last night
empty empty theater I had my clown salad
do you know what a clown salad is uh I
do not popcorn Peanut M&M's poured in
the popcorn damn I have my clown do you
wait do you order that do they know what
it is or do you mix it together yourself
a do it it's a DIY thing yeah I brought
in my clown salad who you with with the
fam Solo solo operations my wife's in
China right now studying taiichi okay
and uh my son's off at College okay and
I was like a kid in the candy store it
was so and no one was in there no one
was in there no it was wait which one
the first one the new one the new one
new one dead letter office number seven
or whatever it's called it's fantastic I
loved it so much have you seen it
no I again unpopular opinions like
movies with a lot of explosions and a
lot of that kind of stuff going
on they're not my thing man they're
echo's thing this is my favorite action
movie of all time really favorite action
movie of all time there was one of the
James Bonds that was really really good
I forget what it was called one of the
Daniel Craig ones but this was like but
anyways the the moral of this is that
stories right we're huddled in a dark
room and there's a they call it you know
the flickering myth you know the story
that's in front of you and the story of
heroism and and courage and explosions
and trains falling off cliffs and stuff
like that and uh I I just love it you
know the office of stories your podcast
is stories humans gathering sharing
stories TW 12ep meetings are sharing
stories like there's something healing
powerful we need to share and listen to
stories and create stories yeah I was
going to say that as much smack as I
talked about this podcast that we do no
we're just reading books from the
historical stuff but like really that's
what it is it's these long stories of
war and heroism and loss and it's and
nerdy actors and then occasion and
occasionally you bring in me
uh uh I Had Gary sise on here he's
another actor he's awesome have we had
any other actors on here I don't think
so is theovon an actor or is he a
comedian he's terrible actor barely a
comedian he just a funny guy who tells
stories about snakes and toilet paper
yeah and one time I met a girl she had
three legs we called her three-leg Suzie
she's great she gave a mean
anyway
that's pretty much
it
uh number 10 the last thing of 10 things
you know for sure is that I don't know
anything which is an important number 10
right it's an important number 10 that's
again tons of stories in bassoon king
um but it seems like your next book Soul
boom it seems like you're trying to
figure out what you do know or what you
can know or what we're trying to learn
Soul boom why we need a spiritual
Revolution is it you know is this book
trying to learn is it trying to figure
things out what are we doing in Soul
boom yeah so when I wrote bassoon King
there's kind of a thread that runs
through it that a lot of people are
turned off by but I talk about kind of
my faith journey in my spiritual journey
kind of it's woven through the funny
stories and the great thing about
bassoon King and I told him when I was
writing the book I'm like listen it's
going to be 85% funny stories 15% is
going to be faith God questions and
finding my spiritual path and whatever
and you know some people love that stuff
and some people are like but well you
can just skip those paragraphs
but after I did that and then coid hit
and Co kind of shut everything down
right of course we all know that but it
shut down the whole acting industry too
like oh what what the hell am I
going to do and I had just been jotting
down a lot of quotes and ideas and
thoughts and stuff like that I use the
notes app on my iPhone and I'm always
just putting in notes and if I can find
a quote that I like and I was like you
know I do know something I have spent 20
or 30 years thinking very deeply about
spirituality and the big big questions
about like God and the meaning of life
and the nature of love and what happens
when we die and what is the soul I've
read a lot about this stuff I've thought
a lot about it now's my chance this was
my kind of my coid project and you know
I I I wrote up I went to my book agent I
wrote up a little outline and part of
the first chapter and kind of the thesis
of what I wanted to say and I sent it
out we sent it out to 13 of the top
Publishers and immediately rejected by
the top 12
just immediately rejected what about the
people that published bass oh they
passed they passed so fast it would make
your head spin damn dude yeah they never
really liked the fact that I put my
spiritual journey in the they just
wanted funny stories they didn't they
really didn't want that in the book but
they begrudgingly allowed me to put some
of that in and um so finally and number
13 haset God bless you haset they came
in and they were like we love love it
totally get it I think it's important
totally see you doing that we're on
board they've been a great partner it's
pretty rare in this business now granted
part of the reason is because I'm a
known name and they know I'm going to
sell a certain number of books just
because I'm the guy who played Dwight
from the office but yeah so this was
this is really my passion project this
is my like I can get hit by a bus and
die tomorrow I'm fine because in Soul
boom is like anything I've kind of
thought about felt deeply uh I share a
lot about my mental health Journey um
and Recovery Journey um and I truly
believe Joo that we do need a spiritual
Revolution that we keep trying as a
society in contemporary America to put
Band-Aids on a Cancer and there we have
to go deeper as a culture uh as a as a
global culture of humans but as an
American culture especially
to get to the spiritual roots of the
diseases that are afflicting our society
and we're not doing that we just talk
about Democrats and Republicans like oh
I'm gonna vote for him or vote for him
or we're going to pass this legislation
that addresses this and you know you
know it's like you know one of the
examples I I I I started off talking
about pandemics right the global
pandemics we're in the coid C pandemic
everyone knows what that's like but
we're actually under a Pand there's a
number of pandemics that are going on
world wide that are afflicting Humanity
now there's a lot of different solutions
for those pandemics right you've got
income inequality is a pandemic you've
got you know 12 billionaires that own as
much as half of the world's population
that's not fair or right now there's a
lot of different solutions you know
already I can feel people getting a
little prickly like uh oh he's a
socialist no I'm not God bless those
billionaires they worked hard they
deserve their money but we've got to
figure out as a way as a species like
it's still there's still people living
in garbage dumps you know like how do we
how do we Rectify this you know under
God under the Bible under um
understanding that we're all beautiful
Divine Sparks and shards of creation and
and we're all light and love and heart
and how do we take care for the poorest
among us as Jesus would have us do so
these questions like income
inequality it's not so much about I mean
yes you need to pass some legislation
that does certain good things right
whatever that is but we have to go we
have to go deeper racism is a great
example like we've passed a lot of
legislation anti-racist legislation over
the years right we haven't solved it if
anything it's worse now than it was a
long time ago so but we have to go
what's what's the cause of that where
why why are we in this imbalance
obviously there's slavery and stuff like
that we look at the past injustices but
what do we do now putting putting that
aside how do we learn and go deeper and
again it's not going to be with a bill
or the right politician or this that you
can pass all the bills you want if
people are going to hate other people
and dislike them for the color of their
skin and for their culture then we're
screwed so anyways I could go on and on
but um it's about uh looking at using
spiritual tools for our personal
transformation kung fu
TV show personal transformation using
spiritual tools for social
transformation start boom Jinx you
Coke so I mean I could go on and on but
it's a it's a passion project it's
something I feel is really really
important and um um and people have been
digging it so I feel good well one part
of the book that I think kind of
captures a bunch of this stuff is you
have uh you spend some time with uh with
the idea that we create a religion like
you're like all right Blank Slate I'm
just going to create a religion the
religion of Soul boom trademark um and
you kind of go through and and again
this is this all builds throughout the
book and it starts off with sort of I
guess you might say the traditional
things that religions generally contain
and you go through
these sort of initial things that 10 10
Universal truths about religion that all
religions share in common um and and you
you apply these to this new religion
which you know is fictional that you
created we created we put together so
number one a higher
power number two life after death number
three the power of prayer and again this
is coming from the fact that you
researched you read all these different
books you've gone down all these you've
had this spiritual journey of your own
that's where you're you're putting these
things
together Transcendence talk to me about
Transcendence how does Transcendence
play to this yeah so these concepts are
it's really easy to look at the
differences in religions right it's real
easy to kind of say well Hinduism has a
hundred different or a thousand
different gods and it believes X Y and Z
I'm a Christian and I believe in God the
Father and Jesus the Son and the Holy
Spirit and Redemption salvation and
resurrection and Etc that's totally
different right and that's true those
are and it's easy to look at those
differences but we need to stop
sometimes pause
and go to the underlying foundational uh
similarities that connect and bind all
the world's religious faiths so that we
can work together in even greater
Harmony so this section right here I'm
talking about um the things that all
religious faiths have in common um which
is harder to uh underline at certain
points so Transcendence is this idea
that we are more than just our material
selves um we have in all of us in our
hearts in our souls in our guts a
Longing To Belong To Find meaning to
rise above just and and
eating and working and trying to have a
good life right we we have some longing
for something more and this idea of
transcendence which you we can know
through God we can know Transcendence
through prayer we can know Transcendence
through through meditation we can also
know through ART
you know and great art whether it's
Hamlet at a theater or it's going to a
Metallica concert or whether it's
looking at a beautiful painting or
hearing a beautiful poem or dance uh
whatever it is like the art at its best
is Transcendence and you and we all know
and we feel it that that feeling of
upliftment and and inspiration so this
key element that we are more than just
our material bodies we have souls and
hearts that that long for some kind of
meaning bonding Beyond just being flesh
um is part of every Faith
tradition number five
Community um at Soul boom our diverse
Community will Embrace inclusion at
every level more on that in a little bit
a moral
compass this is interesting people AR
people argue about this unpopular opin
what's wrong unpopular opinion but I do
believe that our faith traditions and
that God or a higher power brings us our
um bring brings us our morals and our
sense of right and wrong and that
there's that's different than ethics so
ethics is you know hey it's not cool to
take the drink that you want to take off
the counter at Starbucks just because
it's been sitting there but I'm not
going to do it CU I mean it is like
stealing or whatever but morals come
from a higher place right like you know
it's the Ten Commandments come down from
the mountain and those those don't
really change a lot of things about
religious faiths change from from
religion to religion to religion you
know eat this don't eat this celebrate
this on this day you know give to the
church in this way financially Etc but
this underlying moral compass about we
are answerable for our Deeds when we
pass um we you know the the golden rule
is a perfect example of this you know uh
do do un to others as you would have
them do unto you like that's in every
religious faith in the world that
increases compassion so um we as a
society we've jettisoned religion to a
large degree they you know especially in
the in the secular cities and whatnot
and that's understandable because the
religion has done a lot of bad um
but we've also lost a lot and we see
that in the decades that have followed
since this has been happening since the
60s or 70s a lot of falling off of kind
of basic human decency um Common Sense
morality leading with love and kindness
and and mutual support so I I think
there is a um there is a religious
backbone and inspiration for uh a living
and walking a moral
path be hard don't you think it'd be
hard to get people to agree on what that
thing looks like I don't think so I
don't think so I think you can do the
same thing around morality and you can
break it down into like 10 basic kind of
morals you know just even go with the
golden rule you know that doesn't again
it doesn't have to do with politics it
doesn't have to do with you
know it's uh yeah it's it's not you know
it's it's it's leading with kindness
love generosity and compassion and
letting that letting that guide us well
that's the next one number seven the
force of
love that's in every religious Faith y
um you give a warning here that this is
going to get all
corny yeah and we we I try not to use
the L word on the podcast sure just
kidding um increased compassion
certainly something that everyone could
use service to the poor mhm number nine
mhm and number 10 strong sense of
purpose
mhm both the Kung fues individual
answers we seek and the Star Trek like
big picture stuff MH yeah we culturally
we've kind of lost our sense of purpose
we've lost our our goals and uh I again
I try and be as universal as possible I
would love for a Hindu to read this a
Muslim to read this an atheist or
agnostic to read it a born again
Christian to read it and go I relate I I
get that I want it to be inclusive of of
all of those different voices but um one
thing that again we've jettisoned
religion again for a very good reason
because a lot of them have been very
corrupt and done really terrible corrupt
things but in the doing have we lost a
higher sense that there is God the
father and I am in service to his will
the capital H and I want to make the
world a better place and conform my own
behavior and standards to a certain
measures to certain standards of
morality and serve the poor and make the
world better and bring light to the
world just as Jesus did brought light to
the world in so many different ways and
and and the apostles I don't want to
follow in those footsteps steps and we
can do that individually we can do it as
a family we can do it as a community and
we can do it as a nation and that
doesn't mean converting everyone to a
certain religion but but honoring these
kind of basic found foundational aspects
of faith and we didn't go uh like you
said you talked about 15% of the bassoon
King talks about the spiritual side and
you give a pretty good which I didn't
really cover but the bahai faith this is
very bigh Fai is in the fact that seems
like bahai the the premise is very
open-minded with like yep all religions
have good aspects to them and it's all
the kind of the there's a lot of
similarities would you say that's an
assessment that's accurate yeah this is
a lot of it is very bahai inspired I try
and not make it a a bahai book or it's
not about the bahai faith or to convert
people to bahai you know it's mentioned
a few times in the book but this idea
that there are universals in in
religious faith and that that these
universals are beautiful and true we
should honor those and um you know
there's only one God and we're all
ultimately in service to this one God
and let's work together arm in- arm side
by side with our sleeves rolled up Hindu
Muslim Jew Christian bah and make the
world a better place um that's that's
really that's really a key part of the
book and a lot of that inspiration does
come from the be Faith which I'm still a
practicing member of I came back around
about 20 years ago or so and um kind of
have dove in and uh I really it's a
beautiful faith I really love
it uh you go on to say this there you
have it the soul boom takes on
religion's fundamental varities these
elements alone are beefy enough for any
upstart belief system but for our
ultimate goal of making Soul boom as
relevant to the present moment as
possible I offer up an additional 10
principles the goal of these next 10
qualities is to show how this new Faith
Community will embrace the ideals needed
to remake and progress our modern world
again this is a like a thought
experiment that you're basically doing
just to let people know you're not
literally trying to convince me to be a
member of the Soul boom but again it's
important to understand that there's a
lot of young people that have just
rejected religion they're like H
religion is can't take it it's
like okay but whatever we lost and if if
it allows you to think about religion in
a different way well what if we just
took the best elements of different
religions and put them together and us
do you know would that work for you so
it's just it's kind of reinvestigating
reimagining rebooting the concept of
what a religion itself is yeah and I
love this opener no
clerics like what would you think about
a religion with no clergy so this is
there's not going to be some people that
are in charge of the rest of us yeah
yeah I the be faith has that the 12ep
meetings have that the 12 step the 12
steps and AA is the most successful
spiritual religious movement of the 20th
century of the last 150 years by far and
many people are on AA or 12ep do you
know is there a number I'm sure there is
can you get on that Echo yes sir Eko
doesn't do that stuff he doesn't did
other pods have someone Googling in the
corner like yeah bring it up right here
other podcasts have people that sit
there for a long period and they go you
know what I could probably serve a
purpose here whatever so they say you
know what I'm going to get a computer
I'm going to start googling some stuff
if anybody asked me but you know what
Echo he's over there you know he's made
a couple notes and whatnot and he
pressed record a few hours did he did he
checked the mics we're getting no
information security if someone came in
that door he'd be all on them he's a
black belt protect protecting you thank
you thank you uh I wonder how many
people are into 12ep yeah I mean there's
got to be in every
city thousands thousands yeah yeah no
question yeah it's tens of millions how
when did you get into that um I kind of
got into it backwards when I started
doing therapy and I was really unhappy
and then um I realized that I had been
using drugs and alcohol for a super long
and porn and you name it to kind of like
soothe Escape medicate my pain and then
my therapist was like you might want to
check out the 12 Steps because there's a
room full of people that have gone
through the same thing so I was already
it was kind of weird I kind of they call
it white knuckling it where you you get
sober without without the support of 12
steps but I I was sober at that point
and then I but then I started going to
meetings so do you you don't do any
drugs or alcohol right now I don't know
how long have you been clean for it's
it's been a long time about 20 20 years
years yeah
nice uh
and that 12st step you said you got into
it backwards because you I had already
been sober for I think it was a year and
a half before I entered 12ep was there a
rock bottom to that oh you you want to
go there don't you I mean let's do this
you already talked about freaking Harry
Potter you know oh cuz I insulted Harry
Potter yeah now we're bringing the now
we're bringing the Thunder yeah so my
story is a little different and I would
love to indulge you and say there I was
Joo covered in my own vomit lying in the
gutter and my life wife had left me and
my left eye was gouged out by a hobo
with a spear but I don't have that I
don't have that story um so much as just
a lot of time of of just
being for me it's mostly about anxiety
so I have an anxiety disorder for a
while I was on medication now I don't go
on medication for it but I was trying to
medicate on all these different ways so
it just was years and years of
unhappiness of unbalance There Was You
Know difficulties in my marriage
difficulties in my life from from the
stuff that I was using and you know I
went into therapy and um was just deeply
unhappy and um felt really lost and and
then realized that this is what was
wrong with me so I I I'd love to bring
you that hitting bottom kind of that
beautiful podcast hitting bottom story
but it's not really about that so much
as um like I was imbalanced I was
unhappy I was trying anything and
everything I could to medic even even
career ambition can be a medication for
anxiety and and and hating yourself
right so part of it for me was like
trying to get that next level as an
actor was like that'll make me feel
better and that's a culturally
sanctioned one you know we live in kind
of a workaholic world right where it's
like
you are nothing without your career
success and and that's not true you are
something you are beautiful you're
special you're a child of God you're a
spark of the Divine and your mission is
to bring out your
greatest possible Joo you know your
greatest possible Ekko your greatest
possible rain Wilson as under the eyes
of of the all- watching all powerful God
and and which is love and
so it was it's been a long process in
therapy and in 12ep and in service and
um but you know I used to be crippled by
this stuff and now I wake up grateful
and um and content and and focused on
doing the next right thing and this
process of you know this three-fold
process of therapy 12st step and then my
spirituality my as a bigh and and
studying and writing spirituality the
meditation and prayer that I do that
this combination has really made my life
so much better and uh I'm just I'm so
grateful so anxiety
yeah what what is
that like what does that feel like what
is it what do you when you're like I
have anxiety what does that feel like
what are you thinking about what's going
through your mind I actually really love
this question and it's a really
important question because people don't
people don't ask that question so we're
not able to kind of start at the very
beginning so for anyone interested in
this work and you should have him on the
podcast before he dies Dr Gabor mate and
I know he's been on lots of other
podcast he is the authority on addiction
and Trauma and the way he speaks about
it is like he is uh he's incredible I
mean I I he's I he's the Albert Einstein
of addiction and trauma and um he's been
a lot on a lot of other pods and he's so
so brilliant so there's a couple of
different ways that anxiety works so
number one there's normal anxiety like
oh I'm doing this podcast here in San
Diego I wonder what the traffic is going
to be like to La like oh I'm supposed to
be on that call at 6 am I gonna make it
like that's anxiety right but that's
normal anxiety and that's going to come
every day that's going to come 20 times
a day to you right young people don't
quite understand that it's okay to have
that kind of anxiety to worry about the
future and oh is this going to be okay
or is that person mad at me or whatever
it is so that's one part of anxiety for
me picture this toddler and we had a lot
of laughs at the size of my head and
whatnot but there's nothing more
traumatic or sad than a toddler being
abandoned at a year and a half and not
having a mother have you ever seen a
year and a half year old when your kids
were a year and a half what was their
relationship to their mom yeah 100% just
all about the mom mom I was like a like
a foreign being I mean maybe a year and
a half they were starting to be okay
with me but that for yeah they they it's
just all about the mom yeah so for me to
have that taken away there's a something
working on my nervous system that is
like where's my mom or where's my place
where's my meaning where's my how am I
going to be held am I going to be safe
like and that's Primal right that's in
the hippocampus that's in the base of
the brain you know that's the animal
flight fight response stuff it's
physiological so that showed up in a lot
of different ways throughout my life and
it it showed up in anxiety attacks in my
20s where I would literally so funny I
was talking to this young woman and she
was saying like oh I had an anxiety
attack CU I was so afraid that my tax
bill was coming in the mail and that I
saw and I had an anxiety it's like you
didn't have an anxiety attack an anxiety
attack is you think you're going to die
your heart is pounding your lungs can't
get in enough air you're sweating and
you're on the floor and your muscles are
tensing without you telling them to do
it that's an anxiety attack and I used
they're still very common I used to get
them by the dozens in my 20s and guess
what a little little vodka made me feel
better you know a little hit up little
to made me feel better and kind of took
that edge off so I thought but it was a
short-term solution so there's that kind
of anxiety that has to do with um trauma
and a lot of people have that link to
anxiety and Trauma and maybe they were
abused as children or or beaten or had a
a difficult time whatever bullied even
um so those are two different kinds of
trauma I mean anxiety excuse me and then
um
the thing that uh had a therapist say to
me once which I really loved which was
trauma is merely an unidentified
need so I keep saying
trauma anxiety is merely an unidentified
need and I love that so if you're
feeling that like
unsettled
shaky
fearful feeling inside the next thing is
like you don't have to be a victim to
your anxiety so how do you proactively
tackle anxiety here I am I'm having this
it doesn't have to be an full-on anxiety
attack but I'm feeling it how do I what
do I
need do I need a hug do I need a nap do
I need to work out do I need to get into
nature do I need to put my phone down
and the screens down and away from me do
I know need to go to the beach and watch
the sunset do I need to call a friend do
I need to get some therapy do I need to
you know stop drinking caffeine all day
long do I you know whatever it is
there's so many different ways to do I
need to meditate there's so many
different ways to to tackle that but
it's it's and I love this idea that
anxiety is um what what is the canary in
the coal mine it's it's there to help
you it's saying you need something so
it's a good thing if you feel anxiety oh
it's a good thing it's telling me I need
something but what what you don't need
is you know a shot of whiskey and a and
and an edible to soo it you're because
then you're not really getting out the
the real need that's underneath
that so when you go into
therapy they're starting to talk about
like what is the need that you have
because you can't identify it yourself
yeah I needed a lot of help I needed
years of help to kind of identify those
those needs I was really not good at it
can you think your way out of anxiety so
if I'm me and I'm 20 years old and I
graduated from high school didn't go to
college I got a girlfriend I'm starting
to think like how am I going to pay for
her and I don't really have a good job
lined up and all of a sudden I don't
know what I'm going to be doing in five
years and she's starting to look at
other guys because like so this is to me
like what I think would cause anxiety to
a 20-year-old me right like I don't know
what the future holds everything seems I
don't know what I'm going to be doing
and if I just think about dayto day like
hey I'm going to the ball game tonight
I'm going to whatever then I can kind of
it's okay but as soon as I start
thinking about the future and like
what's going to be where am I going to
be how am I get money how am I going to
pay for this and is that like an example
of where anxiety comes from well that's
that's one of the aspects of anxiety
that's kind of the first kind which is
and it's very real like how am I going
to pay this rent you know and am I going
to lose my job am I going to lose my
girlfriend fear of the future can be an
anxiety right right so in the 12 Steps
we learn the Serenity Prayer God grant
me the serenity to accept the things I
cannot change the courage to change the
things I can and the wisdom to know the
difference there's certain things you
can't there are certain things you can
control show up to your job and do a
better job go to your girlfriend tell
her your love her and be good to her
that that's in your control but whether
she leaves you or whether you get fired
that's out of your control right so
there that and it's called The Serenity
Prayer because you gain Serenity by
using that that particular tool so
anxiety can be and it usually is a
little deeper than that it's kind of
like something is wrong inside I'm in
Bal something is out of balanc and I'm a
and I am deeply afraid for myself and
often times you can't really put your
finger on what it is and that's why you
see so many kids in their teens and 20s
right now living in anxiety and in then
it's an anxiety filled world right so
we've got climate change climate anxiety
is a very real thing thing that you know
young people are feeling there's
political Discord and and rage um social
media is really divisive and um you know
we live in this technological World a
lot of kids are being raised by all
their different screens they got their
phone and their iPad and their laptop
and their TV and there that's how
they're being raised so you know this
we've seen anxiety go through the roof
but um yeah I so we've talked about a
lot about not a lot but we talk about
depression sometimes on this and we talk
about that people get stuck in the way
I've described it is like people get
stuck in like a cloud like a storm cloud
right and like let's say you are all
depressed and you're sad and you're
bummed and I'm looking at you from the
outside and I can see that the storm
cloud is just around your head you just
need to like come to hey you know rain
come here walk three steps forward and
you're going to be out of this thing but
you look in 360° you don't see a way out
right it's all around you and it's the
same thing with a like you can see
people that hey man drinking is ruining
your life right now and you need to stop
if they don't see that or this girl that
you've been going out with that's a
psycho or this guy that you've been
going out with a psycho is ruining your
life we can see it from the outside so
clearly and yet they can't see it um so
when it comes to anxiety if I'm like Hey
listen rain like the things you're
worried about you don't need to worry
about these things but it's like
impossible for me to tell you that I
can't explain to you that you're
addicted can't explain to you that this
girl's horrible for you I can't explain
to you that you don't need to worry
about this thing in the future I can't
explain to you that you don't need to
worry about like hey you know who cares
about the reviews that you get it
doesn't matter you're like doing great
it's going to be great you're like no
like I can tell you that but it's like
something that you have to discover for
yourself is that what happens and if
that's what happens do you have a
pathway to talk yourself through these
situations or is it what we talked about
is it the 12 step is it the faith
you know is that what we're doing I love
it again such a great question and you
had asked before about can you think
your way out of it yes and no so you had
Ryan holiday on here right love Ryan and
stuff the work he's doing the stoicism
stuff I've learned so much from him he
would have some really key things to say
from the stoics that I don't really know
he'd be quoting like every one of them
14 times five minutes exactly and I'm
sure because I'm sure that the stoics
dealt with this exact same thing and
probably let's let's all go to his
YouTube channel and check out you know
what he what he would say so and there
and so much of stoicism is like just
about having wisdom and thinking clearly
so so in some in some regards some
thinking can help there's a type of
therap therapy called cognitive
behavioral therapy and for people who
are skeptical of therapy and think it's
too ooey gooey that is a very Cog uh
CBT cognitive behavioral therapy is very
meat and potatoes kind of like oh you're
afraid of flying okay let's look at the
data around flying let's pretend you're
on an airplane let's let's talk about
that why don't you Journal about like
it's really about getting the stuff
that's what they call limic which is at
the base of the brain where you're in
that animal fight flight response and
getting it up into your conscious
cerebral cortex of which I have a
gigantic one and um um I was thinking
about renting out space here a little
billboard little neon billboard fuel on
there I get you some money for that
seriously
absolutely done deal oh my God that'd be
a great science fiction thing is it you
rent out space on your forehead for
advertising oh my God this is great yeah
we're doing this there you go it's on um
so that's very much about thinking but
the the problem with thinking is that
and this starts to get a little
bit crazy do you ever meditate no okay
so in meditation there is this element
where you're you're the Buddhists call
it the monkey mind right so you're it's
like a popcorn machine up in your brain
right you're talking about someone in
the fog and they're not able to see it
so you meditate and then your thoughts
are still bouncing around you kind of
let your thoughts go and then you hit a
certain point and it's really not that
difficult to do where you're kind of up
above yourself not not floating above
hippie dippy stuff but you're just
literally seeing yourself in your
thoughts and you're a little detached
from your thoughts and maybe you have
some thoughts but you have this other
part of yourself that's kind of like
witnessing the thoughts and that's the
witness part of ourselves and that's our
higher self that's our that's our true
self so then you can kind of look down
on your thoughts and like oh I wonder if
I could call them back oh I didn't
return that text oh shoot I was supposed
to pick up a mango for dinner uh you
know you know all of that kind of stuff
and you realize oh that's not me that's
that's my thinking brain which is really
important we need that but that's not
who I am so medit gets you closer in
touch with your real self your present
self your ancient self that W is the
witness so I would say that thinking can
be very limited as we know because we
it's very hard to think yourself out of
a situation but even even like what you
talked about like you have to find it
for yourself yes you do have to find it
for yourself but we can do that in
community we can do that in relation
with each other so therapy is simply a
process of like you're paying someone
you ultimately gain their trust and they
trust you so you're not no no
one else is listening you can lay
everything out on the table and be like
I hate this I and one time
I did this and when I was a kid I stole
it and you could just lay it all out get
the shame out of the way and the
therapist is just so present for you and
then the Pres the therapist is very keen
at seeing all those behaviors you know
the girlfriend the drinking whatever it
is is and it isn't going to tell you
what to do but is going to tip little
breadcrumbs lead you down the path so
that you make that decision yourself in
the 12-step program it's a similar thing
in that you share at meetings so you
turn your anxieties your fears your
issues into stories and you share them
and then you pick up the phone a lot of
the 12 step meetings is just staying in
touch with guys from the program and
then laying it out I I do it all the
time every day I vent about something
I'm like pissed at this or I'm a afraid
of this and and and you share and
there's healing in that and sometimes
you get feedback or you solicit feedback
if you trust someone enough what do you
think you know and so that's part of
that healing of anxiety too so there's a
lot of tools out there and um there's a
lot of people that know this stuff way
better than me but it's it's the disease
of the Modern
Age okay so I'm glad I really like dove
into this because okay so I I wrote a
book called leadership strategy and
tactics in this book leadership strategy
and tactics I talk about this idea of
Detachment which I call a superpower and
I I explain where I discovered it for
the first time I was doing some training
and I was uh assaulting a t a training
Target and in order to figure out what
was happening I had to like take a step
back literally take a step back off the
firing line and look around and I was
able to see what was happening and I was
able to make a tactical decision when no
one else really did even though I was
really young and really Junior
and when we got done with this training
Evolution I was like wait a second how
did I know what to do and no one else
did it's because I took a step back I
detached I looked around and I could see
and then I started doing that when I was
having conversations with people when I
was starting to feel like I'm getting
mad about something I could just learn
to detach and so the and that's why I'm
curious about this stuff because when
like we're talking about anxiety I
literally don't know what it is and and
the reason I don't know what it is is
because I'm taking a step back mentally
looking at it going oh you're freaking
out that's your ego talking that's your
emotions talking you're worried about
something that you can't control and
I've always kind of wondered why I don't
know what it is and why I'm able to deal
with things cuz I am able to deal with
things you know I've been through some
pretty relatively hard things and I'm
like okay with it and now I'm from
hearing what you're describing I'm like
oh yeah I have seen those things in my
brain but it's from a detached
perspective so I see myself oh you're
getting caught up in the fact that you
have lost some friends and you can't
bring them back and you should be mad
about that oh that's that's your
emotions and you're getting too
emotional and you're letting that or oh
this person did me wrong and I'm going
to make them oh no that's just your ego
talking they actually won and beat you
fair and square and that's why you
should just congratulate them for doing
well so when I was when I was asking you
can you think your way out of it that
was the wrong way of of describing what
I was thinking because to you thinking
is like getting wrapped up in the
emotions and the ego and all that chaos
to me thinking is like hold on a second
take a step back what I should have said
can you detach and look at it and see it
from the outside because that's truly
what we want to do you know I'm looking
at you and I see that you're caught in a
storm cloud what I want to be able to do
is like hey bro just just come over here
everything's going to be okay you just
come a little bit forward but you like
you said
I have to get you to see that for
yourself I have to get you to see that
this woman that you're involved with is
is a train wreck or this drug that
you're using is a disaster or this job
that you got is you need to get away
from it or whatever the case may be I've
got to get you to be able to see that I
can explain it to you all day you won't
listen you can't it doesn't change your
point of view for me to explain it to
you 20 times at some point I can try and
explain it at some point you've got to
step out and you've got to take a look
at it and go holy Joo I see what
you're talking about this is bad I'm
going to quit drinking I'm going to get
rid of that girl I'm going to quit this
job whatever that thing is I'm going to
lose my ego I'm going to stop thinking
comparing myself I'm going to stop
reading the the reviews in the New York
Times about my acting or whatever the
doesn't matter the doesn't
matter okay I get it I'm going to put my
ego aside so to me that's a very
powerful thing and again it takes work I
got I stumbled into it as a young frog
man I stumbled into the fact that oh
taking a step step back and looking
around is very beneficial and I added it
to everything in my life I haven't I was
actually one of my questions I was going
to ask you like what do you do in
therapy like what do they do and you've
kind of explained it now so I don't have
to cross that if written it down look at
this three times I've written down
therapy question mark therapy question
mark th I don't know what the hell
happens in there but I'm like how how
does it help you now you've explained
like oh they're asking you questions
they're they're they're luring you out
of your brain they're luring you out of
your brain so that you can see what it
looks like and go oh let me let me
amend that a little bit because if
you're just talking from a physiological
perspective like huberman might you know
you're you're not luring it out of the
brain you're luring it from one part of
the brain to the other part of the brain
so so much of anxiety fear aggression
depression is happening at our lizard
part of our brain and it's just firing
down there and then and and again
therapy may not be your bag there's a
lot of different ways to do it you know
you might do it in church or or through
a a group or just with friends or
whatever but you're physiologically
taking all of that activity in the brain
stem and you're moving it up into the
cerebral cortex so by talking about it
you're then able because this is where
all the higher functioning stuff happens
so you take it out of the lizard brain
and you move it into the into the angel
brain trademark rain Wilson 2023 boom
you said it on my podcast so it's
actually so how much IP do you own brain
ual
property I never should have come on
here uh but you but but that's part of
the process so part of the talking and
therapy it's like and it gets a bad WP
but part of it is to take you know your
fear your shame your anxiety your
depression um th those deepest darkest
things that are like going on way down
there in the shadows in the corner of
the closet bring him to the front of the
closet shining a nice light on it and
then you're able to make some decision
okay once that's happened now what are
you going to do so you're not a victim
what choices are you going to make
because it can't some therapy is bad
because it just stays there in the
talkie talk and it's like talk for a
while get it into the light and like
what what are the three things you're
going to do every day to make this
better and a good therapist will lead
their client toward be making proactive
decisions where they're no longer a
victim yeah that that was another thing
that I found
found when people would ask me about
like grief and one things it's like
I unfortunately have had to write a lot
of eulogies right and I realized that in
doing that oh that was a way for me to
process that was a way for me to think
through that was a way for me to bring
some of those uh emotions to the surface
and be like okay I can see them now I
can let them out here we go and that's
why you know what you're saying about
therapy is something that I've done
through writing yeah and even if it's
just writing a eulogy which is a
horrible freaking task you know it's
been 17 hours hey they want you to talk
like or you know hey are you going to
speak yes I am it's like okay it's been
17 hours and now I have to write and I
got to get these things out on paper and
that stuff is so helpful to be able to
do that um which that's part of
journaling is a very valuable tool that
does that exact same thing and that's
what you're talking about and then in 12
steps you do step work so you're doing
that same thing but again that's always
a process of taking it down from the
lyic system to the higher part of the
brain there's more to it than that but
that's one of the elements of
it okay uh going back to the soul boom
religion here number 12 diversity plus
Harmony number 13 centrality of the
divine feminine talk to me on that
one so in some of my reading and
research I noticed that um the
humanity put uh kind of the feminine dis
Divine at uh the center of
conversation of worship um early on in
Humanity's history and then around 3,000
5,000 BC it became all about the
conquerors and the god of you know the
god of ER or the god of Babylon or the
god of Baghdad or the god of Judea or
whatever that that conquered then you oh
you guys have to worship this God and
it's usually a battle God and a war God
and you know the Greek War gods and
stuff like that so um but before all
that it was much more of goddess and uh
feminine qualities um nature it had to
do with birth it had to do with the
seasons and um a connection to the
Divine was found through kind of
feminine more feminine qualities and I
do think that we you know I'm sitting at
a table covered in knives but I do think
that we've kind of um we've over
masculinized our our contemporary world
and I don't mean that to be at all like
some kind of criticism of masculinity
masculinity and
Leadership honor integrity being a
provider knives
it's an occasional knife an occasional
gun when necessary I don't know about
having 45 guns in a closet but um but
this stuff is really important right but
we've just got we've just skewed in the
balance a little bit and so it would be
good to kind of reexamine some of that
some of those feminine elements
especially of of the Divine and worship
and connection to like Mother Earth and
just like the beauty of Nature and the
birth cycle and Springtime and what
happens with flowers with with baby r we
have all these rabbits in my property
and all these baby bunnies hopping
around in you know and it's like the
Easter Bunny and literally is the spring
and it's these little e they're Easter
Bunnies everywhere you know but a
reconnection to that I think is
something we could benefit from a
conversation
about um number 14 cooperation between
science and
Faith number 15 profound connection to
the Natural World MH i surf usually when
people ask me if I meditate I say I Surf
and I do Jiu-Jitsu because from what I
understand that's a lot can you do both
at the same time no well uh no I can't
you need to detach a little bit more
detach
harder profound connection to the
natural world no but you're you're
absolutely right that you know we think
of this as meditation but walking in the
woods is meditation walking on the beach
is meditation and certainly surfing is
meditation the ACT but also all that
time you're out there like on your just
like you know like it's it's so soothing
and healing also it's important to
understand that walking is a is a
meditation in and of itself they've done
studies about walk we stopped walking 70
years ago humans used to walk for a 100
thousand years all we did was walk
around all the time and there's
something healing about walking and it
literally heals the brain like your left
hemisphere and right hemisphere the
impulses go back and forth while you're
walking and it's it's brain healing and
they've done studies about how walking
reduces anxiety how it dep reduces
depression CU then you've got kids all
day sitting like this and they're not
using their legs so that's a different
kind of meditation as well there's a lot
of physiological ways to do it and I
play tennis and I find very meditative
because in tennis you've got to just
look at the ball that's it you can't be
thinking about your email you need to
write you're just like you just have to
see the ball I imagine in Jiu-Jitsu it's
all about being completely in the moment
like what's your opponent throwing you
and what's you're in and stuff like that
so all of a sudden you're out of an hour
and a half session you're like what an
hour and a half just went by seriously
like holy you know and I feel that
way coming out of a out of a tennis game
I never heard that thing about walking
before but it definitely makes sense
because it's one of those things where
it's like it's like when you were a kid
like go for a walk like to calm down
right you need to go for a walk around
the house and then you think about when
everyone got locked down during Co oh my
God I never thought of that before
they're like yo you can't even walk
anymore you just sit here in your
room wiping down your groceries oh my
God it got crazy uh number 16 centrality
of
Justice what is that all
about uh I think that um there's we
think about Justice in terms of like the
court system right or Congress or the
Supreme Court or something like that but
there is um uh there is right and wrong
it's connected to morality there's like
right and wrong and Justice what's what
what is right and what is wrong is
inherent in uh belief systems and for me
it would be really important to if
you're creating this madeup fake
religion to have Justice be a part of it
or conversations about what is again
it's just what is just what is fair what
is right and wrong and then how can we
use spirit spiritual tools to
help you know move that forward not
necessarily the court system but how can
we Rectify Injustice by using greater
spiritual
Powers number 17 a life of
service number 18 practical spiritual
tools what's your top spiritual
tool well you know I talked about
meditation that's one the tools about
like detaching from your thoughts that's
a that's a spiritual tool that
literally I can sit down and five
minutes and my life is in shambles I'm
and I can just kind of go like this and
I can breathe and just detach with love
from my own thought process and I can
gain greater Clarity right and really
anyone can if you're just taking some
deep breaths that just taking some deep
breaths as a form of meditation right he
taught you how to meditate I just taught
myself cool no big
it doesn't have to be fancy you don't
need a fancy teacher or an app or
anything like that although there's lots
of great tools out there and there's a
lot of them are free on
YouTube um but uh Russell Brand has a
great uh he does some meditation yeah
yeah for um talks on podcast and um I
will here's one from the bahai
faith uh the son of the founder of the B
Faith whose name was Abdul Baha he said
if a man has 10 good qualities and one
bad quality focus on the 10 and forget
the one if a man has one good quality
and 10 bad qualities focus on the one
and forget the 10 and that's a lot
easier said than done right so we work
with people right and maybe they're just
great all around but they've got one
quality maybe they don't listen
very well or they interrupt you or
something like that but otherwise
they're they're kind they're good guys
they this and isn't that funny how we
just are like God this guy always
interrupts me and we don't look at like
oh he's compassionate he's kind he's
smart he's funny he's this or that we
just look at that one thing right and
and likewise you got to work with people
that have the office is a great example
of this you know they have 10 bad
qualities you know they sometimes
sometimes I have dealt with people that
have tried me so much and tested me so
much and I'd love to hear the the
military version of this when you're
with a platoon of guys like and you each
other's sweat and you're in the
same bucket and stuff what that's like
but you know I've had to work with
people where it's literally like
everything they say and do drives me
baty and bugs the out of me so I
just have to find that one part of like
oh they have kind eyes or oh they're
very well groomed or or they seem to be
patient or whatever it is you find that
one thing like focus on this it's a
practical spiritual tool to make your
life better and make your day better so
you're not spending your whole day going
like jao does this and Ekko does this
and why does Bobby always do that and
you're just spending all your time
focusing on all of the the negativity
around you it's a way to focus on the
positive had a guy named uh Captain
Charlie Plum on this podcast he was a
pilot in Vietnam he was shot down on his
75th Mission which would have been his
last mission he was shot down and
captured and he was put in the Hanoi
Hilton for six years Jesus and he had
this they had a rule those prisoners of
War had a rule and the rule because they
would be put in um prison cells and
they'd have a roommate and usually
they'd have a roommate for like six
months a year year and a half and then
they'd get another roommate sometimes
they were in three-man rooms two man
rooms four man rooms but this is the
deal this is what they're dealing with
but they had a rule that if your
cellmate did something that annoyed you
it was your fault and to me that answers
the question you just gave like like you
you and I are living in a cell and every
night while I'm trying to go to sleep
you're like picking your nose and like
flicking your boogers onto the wall near
my head it's like you know me exactly
you seem like a booger flicker I've
sensed it immediately but I don't sit
there and go why is he doing this
instead I go I this is my fault for
letting this annoy me it's my fault and
that's just a a great way to do it it's
a great way to turn it and it's a
survival skill cuz if you're going to
sit in that cell and just be annoyed by
everyone for six years I went to that
hanoy Hilton last year did you um yeah
when I was arrested by the Lake Forest
Park Police Department in uh
1981 um no I went on vacation to uh uh
to Vietnam which is aesome did you have
flashbacks when you're in the h Hilton
of the Lake Shore Police Department I
did holding cell like oh man the god me
where's Terry man they killed Terry
Terry come
back incoming um in the words of theovon
everybody's got their Vietnam
man that's great but uh yeah Vietnam is
a great place by the way and and the
Vietnamese people are so awesome and
beautiful and they love Americans and
they really actually don't like the
Chinese but they love Americans and they
totally cuz that people go even went
like am I going to look weird like we
invaded your country and bombed your by
the way yes you are going to look weird
but well anyways you were saying they
looked up at me and they like who is
that giant white Macy's day balloon of a
fleshy cor pusle above me but uh it's a
great place people are so warm and
wonderful and and Hanoi is a gorgeous
City but the Hanoi
Hilton wow it's uh it's a it's like
visiting a Holocaust Memorial or
something it's just
anyway yeah six years six years yeah
totally insane um
and all right number 19 emphasis on
music and
arts yeah I think all too often we lose
the sight of the fact that uh so much of
religion and faith and spiritual
celebration at its best incorporates
music and dance and arts and and drama
and storytelling look at the success of
a lot of the Christian films uh recently
and you know how uplifting music is at
church and stuff like that so in this
fictional religion of Soul boom think
that Arts need to be a part of it I I
access I access so much of like
heart-based spiritual feeling through
ART and through through music and um I
could never be a part of like some kind
of boring practice that doesn't feature
the Arts yeah you pointed that out
earlier uh talking about the veterans
and there's a lot of like art therapy
that guys will go to and they'll start
doing whatever freaking crochet or pain
or whatever and it like makes them feel
better yeah so there you go yeah uh and
the last one is I see your crocheting
your crocheting is a big one for me yeah
yep number 20
humility and last but certainly not
least Soul boom Faith admits that it
doesn't know the best way to do anything
we don't have any absolute answers we
we're in a humble posture of learning we
provide but a few markers guidepost and
clues along the winding path of the
spiritual Game of Life a marshal of
meaning a supcon of Serenity is that the
word sup Su
a a kernel of the Eternal I like that
one hey and plenty of questions along
the way so you you you know to me and
I've always right and say humility is
the most important characteristic for
leaders and for people to have and it's
what we're lacking a lot of in the world
right now yeah absolutely because I
actually think I know exactly what the
answer should be and therefore I hate
you because you don't agree with my
answer everyone does just look at
Twitter or X all you have to do is read
X and everyone knows the best way yeah
yeah so Soul boom our fictional religion
is a humble religion yeah I think that
one of the things that has turned so
many young people off from religious
faith is kind of like this kind of like
certainty and judgment um pronouncements
this is the way it is so we just have to
you know as we walk our spiritual path
keep openhearted and keep questioning
and um and stay humble and you know not
always think we know the best way you
know it's hard it's hard for me because
I know a lot and I usually do know the
best way I'm kidding but uh but it no it
really is important and I love that you
say that about leadership because it's I
know it's part of your dichotomy you
know of leadership but the uh you know
humility and service and really
surrender and that's an interesting
thing about 12-step recovery too is that
you find strength and surrendering
that's like weird and it's
counterintuitive like strength is
willpower like you have a you know
alcohol problem or a sex problem or a
shopping problem or an eating problem or
a relationship problem and like you just
got to will yourself out of it and you
know and will and determination are
important qualities human qualities we
wouldn't have have our civilization
without it but sometimes there are
things that you just have
to that you have to surrender and then
in that surrender you find great
strength and uh and that's that's an
interesting one as well yeah that's an
interesting one too when it comes to
like leadership from a a humility
perspective you have to have a like a
high level of confidence in order to be
humble so it's always the people that
lack confidence that don't act humble
but if I'm actually confident I'm like
oh you know what rain it sounds like you
got a better plan than I do why don't we
go ahead and use your plan yeah whereas
if I'm if I lack confidence then I'm
like you know what my plan's better go
with my plan Y and that's problematic
all day long yeah indeed uh and then you
do have one bonus thing which I think is
a a big hit here for your religion it's
a potluck potl because potl
play a huge part in bringing people
together is one of the greatest
contributions to human civilization
brought To Us by our Native American
brothers and sisters the uh everyone
brings a hot dish and uh my dad had one
recipe it was a tater tot casserole nice
and it was
um uh cream cream
soup and uh I think a layer of tater
tots and then more cream soup and then
cheese and the tater tots and and then
cheese bake on 350 for like 20 minutes
you just put the Frozen T and then it's
it's so good I thought you were going to
say potato chips on top cuz I know my
mom would make like the whatever kind of
casserole she was making whether itut
casserole Hamburger Helper casserole or
a chicken canned there was potato chips
on top how about this crinkled up clown
salad on
top so this clown salad's a thing it's a
thing
it's a nerd thing you wouldn't
understand um all right so that that's
kind of like one small section of Soul
boom and
again really cool read you did the audio
book which is which is great I listened
to the sample of the audio book as well
and ton of stuff to ponder in here a
very idealistic book yeah it is it's a
very idealistic book and I actually
caught myself being like hold on a
second there who's a freaking think
everyone's just and I caught myself
being like uh kind of a reactionary to
some of your thoughts in there and then
I thought to myself why wait why can't
why not be idealistic why not trying to
do I have to agree with everything that
is said before I say oh wait a second
what what does he mean by that I CAU I
found myself being a victim of my own
what I just talked about like well he
obvously has never been in that
situation before otherwise no it's like
oh what is he trying to say
and are we not better to have an open
mind and this is again this is one of
the things I got asked recently you know
talking about going to war somewhere was
China or Russia or whatever people are
asking me oh what would you be thinking
about and I said uh you know the most
important thing that I would be thinking
about if we were to go to war there
would be having an open mind because I
don't know what's going to happen I
don't know what the enemy is going to do
I don't know the way things are are
going to unfold I don't know what we
haven't thought about and where people
get trapped is they have a closed mind
in in battle and in life they have a
closed mind they already think they
understand kind of like interestingly
you said playing that role where you
bombed on Broadway you already knew in
your mind how you were supposed to act
and that's what you were going to do and
you were going to stick with it you had
a closed mind and not an open mind and
not a humble mind either and not a
humble mind either um well one of the at
the end I put in Seven Pillars of a
spiritual Revolution and because I
really do think it needs a revolution
and one of them is to Foster joy and to
squash cynicism so being cynical and
pessimistic and negative is an easy
fallback position anyone can do it you
can just be like Ah that's a bunch of
that's never going to work out a
that's that's an easy it's an
easy answer it's an easy way to live
your life and I'll join right in with
you cuz that's easy too like you want to
complain about something I'll just and
with you we Brothers now so if if we
think a little bit deeper um you know
squashing that cynicism and instead
turning that to Joy like I'm not helping
anyone I'm not helping myself and I'm
not helping the world staying
pessimistic and cynical I need to bring
joy to the world I'm going to bring joy
to the world but I want to bring I want
to uplift people I want to inspire
people I want to come into a room one of
the thing you know my dad passed during
Co
died of heart disease but when he passed
away um and in my grieving process
thought a lot about his best quality is
like and something that I want to
emulate is like every room he went into
he made a better place every room he
went into even if it's like the cleaning
lady or the hotel maid or he the the
Starbucks or whatever it is like he was
always like Hey Brother nice to see you
like how's it going like oh that's a
nice watch what what what is that like
or how do you shave your head that way
like whatever it is like he's he's
curious and joyful and uplifting and
like and at his remembrances and
memorials like that's what was was
shared like he always made each room a
better place and I'm so fortunate that I
got to he was up in a lot of ways
he made a lot of mistakes he had a lot
of issues but that was a just a
beautiful quality that he brought so if
we're going to have a spiritual
Revolution we can't we you're
pessimistic and cynical you sit back
right when you're joyful you're
proactive and you're making choices to
try and make things better and positive
and it's we talk about a lot about
giving service right and service to
others but spreading Joy is maybe the
most important service that we can do so
we can go into a room you can make
someone laugh you can compliment them
and you can go in to when someone is
sick and and and tell a joke or sing a
song and bring them some Jello or
whatever and you've uplifted them and
made them better that's one of the best
services that any human can give to
another human so if you're feeling a
little bit lost squash that cynicism
just try and give a little bit of Joy
each day and guess what you'll feel
happier by giving joy to others and then
the cycle repeats and we can spread this
like a virus and yeah it's a little bit
Kumbaya and a little bit a little bit
idealistic and and hippie dippy but I
believe that world peace is possible and
I believe that Humanity can mature I
think our lives can get better and we
can make the world a more beautiful and
joyful Place we've just got a lot of
work in front of us got some work to do
on that yeah on that front I was talking
to some young uh some young seals the
other day and yeah yeah and they they
kept going back in the water now I was
talking to these young seals the other
day and you know in it one even once
you're in the SEAL Teams you still do a
bunch of training and I used to run that
training and but I i' had been through
that Advanced Training i' done seven
deployments so seven times I'd gone
through this cycle of training and one
thing I did I always did was no matter
what we were doing as I took it as
seriously as I possibly could like not
serious like oh we're not going to have
fun but like okay this is what we're
doing we're going to do our best at it
not being like Oh we got to do this
again or oh this isn't realistic or oh I
can't believe that no it's like oh this
is what you want us to do cool we're
going to knock it out of the park and
just that
reframing that t taking a positive
attitude on what you have to do it just
makes all the difference in the world
and you can immediately change a whole
platoon their attitude if you have a
shitty attitude your whole platoon's
attitude will be shitty if you have a
good attitude like oh this hey this
training might seem a little bit strange
but it's gonna I bet we can knock it out
of the park and all of a sudden like oh
yeah I think we can and it really does
spread so what you're talking about on a
large scale definitely happens on a
small scale as well
um the so so that's soul boom I don't
know you might have to if we're going to
go in depth on Soul boom you have to
come back bro cuz I mean this is already
getting getting long but you have other
stuff going on right now you have a
podcast metaphysical milkshake yeah is
that not a podcast it is a podcast it's
kind of that one's kind of is it is it
winding down it's sun setting yeah and
uh I did it with Reza Asen we talk about
big metaphysical questions about the
meaning of life and love and pain and
wonder and being a human being it's been
great but um I think I'm going to move
and try and do more of a soul boom
podcast that's a little bit more about
spiritual ideas okay so but in the next
couple of months at some point so TV
show yeah this thing is not sunsetting
I'm the the the uh geography of bliss
that's correct so what's up with
geography of bliss well it's on the
peacock Channel and you can stream it
and I travel around the world looking
for happiness and it's a wonderful
delightful show that I am not allowed to
promote because we're on a strike and
please support the screen actor Guild
and the riters Guild of America in their
quest for ever more fair revenue streams
from these streamers Studios so that's
what's going on right now
yeah um how long is that strike GNA last
oh dear God you know it's really hurting
a lot of working class families people
think about oh Hollywood elites on
strike boohoohoo but the majority of I
think it's like 80 % of Screen Actors
Guild actors make less than $20,000 a
year so it's a lot of working-class
families trying to feed their kids and
pay their homes while being actors and
writers and working in Showbiz a lot of
writers you know the you look at the end
of a show and like the writers that are
there like you know they make a good
living don't get me wrong but they you
know it's it's about middle class homes
so the entire business has changed so we
got to understand this is not just just
a strike of like oh I want a 5% raise
not a 3% raise It's Like Show Business
CH do you remember what show business
was like 7 years ago it was completely
different than it is now everyone had
cable you watch network television and
then there was this net Netflix upstart
and oh should I pay my $9 a month to
watch what's on that one um but this
whole subscription Revenue streamer kind
of thing is a whole new thing and the
contracts don't reflect the new business
model so so that means the people that
wrote them and act in them are not
getting the pay that they think they
should get the office I forget what the
number is Eko can Google it yeah and
then uh that up uh pull that up eeko he
he'll he'll Google it tomorrow and next
Thursday we'll hear from him like Hey I
got that information you wanted um the
uh uh but the office when it was on
Netflix there was some number that came
out it's like 17 billion hours of the
office streamed or something like that
my family alone streamed one billion I
mean it was and yet the checks that we
got in residuals from Netflix for those
years I don't want to say any numbers
but it was it was pathetic I mean it was
it was pathetic like you couldn't pay
your credit card bills from it and we
were being watched billions of ours now
I'm fine Steve's fine John's fine we're
all fine but like some of the guest
stars on The Office and people that are
you know the more work a day actors and
stuff like that not the fabulous stars
um you know that's a that's a real
struggle that's a problem so we have to
we have to figure out how to make that
more fair and Equitable without shutting
down the streamers you know so I I hope
they're talking but it's probably what
month is this this early September but
it's not going to get fixed till
December or January probably it's
already been a couple of months is there
like a head of the Union of the SAG
Union or Fran drer the nanny is the head
of our Union and remember her oh hi I'm
Fran drer The Nanny I don't Echo that
was a mediocre to poor uh imitation but
yes the
nanny he says one thing the whole pod he
hasn't listened to anything I said look
at the 10 good qualities there we go not
my Fran drer
impersonation oh Fran drer I knew
exactly who it was than whatever so what
I'm saying is if we're trying to uh uh
what do you call indicate who friend
dresser is that wasn't as accurate as
maybe it could have been you know to to
trigger the the the memory for us but if
you heard her real voice you'd be TV
show called The Nanny the nanny is a TV
show was a sitcom from the '90s I think
yeah yeah okay so she's like the head of
the union and she's talking to all the
different execs so they have a um a
producer Coalition it's not really a
union it's called aat I think and
Association of I don't know media
producers or something like that and
they have a couple of uh key negotiators
talking on behalf but here's the other
weird thing about the strike is the
streamers have a very different business
model than the studios you think about
like Warner Brothers has HBO Max but it
also puts movies out in theaters it also
has Harry Potter it has theme parks and
it makes TV shows that it sells to
networks and to streamers as well but
Netflix has its own business model you
know it doesn't it doesn't actually make
anything it's just the the platform and
then Apple and Amazon they're making
billions of dollars selling shoes and
computers and then they make some
content on the side they don't care
about these contracts and stuff like
that they're they're trillion doll
corporations so it's a very weird it's
such a weird time time when you have
like Sony which is very specifically a
studio there's no Sony streaming
platform it's a studio that makes
content working with Netflix which is
only a streamer working with apple that
mostly sells phones and they're all like
working together but they kind of have
different
interests whoa it's a weird
time so and so and the other thing is
CUA like I said I've been on a couple of
these TV shows there's a whole there's I
can't imagine all the other people out
the crew the crew the people that make
the set the people that feed every show
you watch and there's like 12 actors or
14 speaking actors on a on a roll
there's 200 people it's crazy 250 people
the camera loaders and the people doing
the the snacks and the the people
cleaning up afterwards driving the
trucks the teamsters and those guys are
hurting too it's hurting a lot of people
and you think hopefully by the end of
the year there's been some progress made
I I hope so what's the outcome like
what's the most most positive outcome
for the writers and the actors is like a
slice of the yeah a bigger a bigger
slice of the streaming pie in a in a
Fair Way um because we used to get a
nice Fair slice of the network pie
that's all been worked out if you go
still now and go do a network show you
know you're gonna you do Bob hars
abishola or you know FBI or you do you
know uh you know Law and Order you know
Chicago or whatever on network TV that's
all been worked out and you get paid
very fairly and residuals get paid
fairly and compensation and pension and
all that's oh but when Law and Order
goes to a streamer you don't get Jack
you don't get Jack yeah and they're and
they're getting like suits is the number
one show on Netflix that was made on TBS
or TNT 10 years ago and people love this
show Suits okay actually David costable
was on suits so but those guys aren't
getting paid didly and it's being
watched for billions of minutes on
Netflix you open your Netflix and the
top show Su is right up there but
they're making hardly any money for that
because it wasn't in the contract but 10
years ago on internet streaming you know
that that wasn't really a thing up until
five or seven years ago so damn and
those contracts are already signed
sealed and delivered yeah we got a so
Stakes are high it sucks um hopefully
everyone can find a solution all right
um does that get us up to speed does
that like are we there yeah we there for
the most part yeah I think we're good
any more insults you want to throw out
at people EO Charles uh where so where
can people find you right now so you got
soul booom domcom yeah and Instagram on
Soul booom atou booom if you're
interested in spiritual conversations
I'm going to be trying to build that out
over the next year you're on Twitter and
Instagram yeah rain Wilson there's two
end NS two NS because your
parents decided an extra n was necessary
yeah I say the extra n is for extra
Nookie you you're you're on Facebook as
well um and you got this other TV show
which we can't promote because you're on
a strike yes the geography of bliss I
will not be promoting on peacock about
finding happiness around the world yeah
awesome uh Eko yes any questions
hard-hitting question hard-hitting
question hey why did they put the office
on the iPad pod they're like why did
that deal go through is that just that's
a great question I have no idea why I
think NBC must have just done a deal
with them to to put it on but I don't
maybe it was an apple thing maybe Apple
was like we need to put a show on that
we think people will like and maybe
maybe NBC was just like oh you can have
the office no one's watching it put it
on for free yeah I don't know I need to
dig into that yeah seems kind of like a
random thing for such a big deal even
you know like something yeah didn't they
put CSI on or something else I don't
know yeah that's crazy um did you hear
you know the movie Office Space yeah did
that is it true that that's like a you
know what do you call like a spin-off or
like a movie version of the off was it
inspired by the office I think it was
before the office I think that came out
in like
2002 but I don't think no the office is
very and you can look at it so
specifically spun off from the British
office but I love office space classic
comedy so many great characters and
there's definitely they have a similar
Vibe at the center you know the
awkwardness and the yeah yeah yeah um
and then Dwight right Dwight are you
allowed to be Dwight officially like at
certain events and like all this bro we
did a um how's this kid so I did a show
called The Hinata lanja show you might
be familiar with it so we do like
parodies of certain one of the best I
mean I don't know is it good if you
don't if you're not in that world is it
good it will be a percentage of good for
sure cuz the you know like a that that
whole idea is funny you know that
trolling idea but yeah if you're in the
Jiu-Jitsu world it's going to be you're
going to get the full The Full
Experience for sure but one of the
parodies we did was remember the
Incredible Hulk the original sure the OG
Lu fro so we did a parody of that intro
to that show you know David Banner or
whatever and so for the Hulk we used
this real famous
wrestler for cuz he's a black guy right
so he turned into the Hulk so he used a
big black um his name was Ezekiel
something he was like a super fan I not
in like WWE WWE guy yes exactly so boom
when he turned in the Hulk I you know
digitally morphed them and all did all
this stuff colored them green and what
but it was this famous wrestler and so
we're like yeah it's going to be perfect
when we do the credits and boom we'll
get all this exposure right through WWE
whatever and you know it comes back hey
we can't use that name cuz that name
belongs to the WWE oh wa so you got to
make up so just made up some funny name
or whatever but it's a famous wrestler
guy Zeke something mhm and he like I
think he like retweeted it real like in
so does WWE own the rock or own Hulk
Hogan I don't know see what is it the
Grave the Grave Digger what's that guy
Digger Undertaker Undertaker
gravedigger's monster trucks right uh I
don't
know cause cause you know Stone Cold
Steve Austin who I've been on his
podcast but right he when you look at
like his Instagram and stuff it's not he
doesn't often refer to himself as Stone
Cold St Steve Austin so maybe there's
the same similar thing going on I do
know that I do know that NBC Universal
owns Dwight shre Dunder Mifflin shuit
Farms the office like all of that stuff
they own all that right um if I went
around dressing up as Dwight to like
make money they could come after me or
something like that if I
although there's so much merch out there
with Dwight that people make on Etsy
like you can go to ety and find thousand
and and NBC isn't Prof they're profiting
from it but they're not shutting it down
either so yeah they could probably they
do they do own that so yeah yeah so cuz
you do it in like charitable situations
right like how you how you said so yeah
it feels like I do some Dwight t-shirts
and I suppose that I sell for charity
but I suppose NBC could be and
come after me and say you can't have it
and everything that goes on in that show
if you would have made up sh
Farms it's still owned by them because
they're paying you at the time and
that's just the way it works yeah 100%
yeah kind of like when you said Angel
brain earlier on this podcast it's my
property exactly no big deal exactly
yeah Angel brain t-shirts sure sh Locker
all day the um so what if and I don't
want to go too deep into this but we're
talking about it so shuit Farms what if
in shuit farms uh what do you call like
um like the myth or the the idea of it
there was maybe a a worker in shuit
farms never materialized but let's say
as an idea then you made a shirt you
know like on Seinfeld I remember
Seinfeld yeah there was uh George would
pretend that he was like an architect or
whatever ortex vandaway or something
vand Industries was one of the things
he'd purport to be like this guy of
right vandelay Industries so make sure
it's saying vlay Industries right so
it's kind of part of the ethos part of
the you know well not the ethos but part
of the myth you know so I wonder how
deep you have to go with Dwight and his
whole you know
atmosphere yeah I think anything that
you did that's related to shuit Farms or
something like that in any way I think
they they're going to own that do that
and they will come after you yeah yeah
what about spin-offs are they must have
proposed a thousand spin-offs for well
we tried to do Dwight spin-off and they
passed on it what and they would have
made a bazillion dollars off a Dwight
spin-off we did one episode in like
season 7 that was called shuit farms and
what we were looking at was what if
Dwight left Dunder mufflin just to focus
on the bed and breakfast at Sho farms
and like Faulty Towers sort of yeah a
little bit Faulty Towers running an inn
you know running a an aggro inn where
you get to see a working farm oh my God
that' been epic and the episode that we
made it was it was really hard to make a
21 minute episode that introduced a lot
of these different characters and stuff
like that but ultimately there were new
people that came in um to run NBC at the
time and they were like they wanted to
get more into big splashy multi- camera
sitcoms and the office was kind of
waning and it's in the last couple years
especially without Steve and so they
were like yeah we're done with the whole
office thing but if they had done sh
farms and we had done even a couple of
Seasons those would be streaming all the
time would it have been as funny as the
office no and that's okay because even
if it was 67% as funny as the office it
would have been really good been damn
funny but that's not going to like all
the people that listen to this podcast
tons of them they're going to re
reignite that idea and you just yeah I
I've talked to them a few times about
like how do we do a reboot of Dwight or
shuit Farms or do we want to and you
know just mostly for me so I've had some
creative conversations and with some of
the producers from the office and stuff
and and it's like I just you know I had
10 glorious years we made a great show
I'm really enjoying the other stuff that
I'm doing other acting and writing and
whatnot do I really want to go back
there right now I don't really but who
knows next year who knows maybe I'll be
like yeah that would be really fun you
know maybe that's a it's a Dwight movie
you know I'm trying to think of is there
examples of this that have happened well
Frasier is the famous spin-off from
cheers got it right that's the one that
really worked where Frasier was maybe
even better than cheers so there's
there's been a few Joey was a spin-off
of friends that only lasted a year or
two didn't do very well tenci d movie
came out right right two of them as a
matter of fact that's off that HBO
series you know there's actually a lot
of them that that started and kind of
even like Seinfeld had a few like CR had
one yeah but it wasn't any character
from Seinfeld it was just Michael
Richard B off of it almost kind of
inspired charact yeah that's true huh he
was was similar to Kramer but he didn't
he was his name wasn't Kramer it's like
cordoza or something how often do you
hang out with the office
people there's a lot of them I see a lot
I see Oscar Brian Jenna Angela you know
I text with John and Steve and a BJ I
hung out with in New York a while back
so I see him here and there but we're
we're spread out out we have a nice text
chain and you know we have a good we
have a good time so text chains are
freaking awesome like you know what I
mean like my family group text is just
like awesomely epic you know what I mean
f and like the Jiu-Jitsu group like the
Jiu-Jitsu training group is like an
awesome text thread of talking and
stuff like this freaking I think there's
going to be a book or a movie or
something that's just nothing but
bubbles popping up with words in them
and memes and and emojis
and the whole deal Echo anything else
that is it oh wait wait this is like off
the topic I guess you ever watch mcgyver
sure that wasn't one of your jams girl I
guess that's a little bit what's the
opposite of ahead of your time like
later a little late mcgyver is a little
bit late but still it's it's in there
yeah yeah yeah I was like in acting
school in New York and I wasn't really
watching M Guyver then there's a whole
period of stuff that I kind of missed
around that that's like what you guys
said said about the '90s whatever show
was in with the girl in the '90s The
Nanny like that that chunk of period
when I was like in the SEAL Teams going
on deployment there's no TV like there's
a whole era that I missed yeah so but
what about it I know just seeing what up
cuz that was one of those ones that when
you're in it well I was like a teenager
at that time but or a kid or whatever
but when you think you're like man this
is the most clever smartest show ever
like he doesn't carry a gun he just
figures things out with the stuff around
him you know like that kind of stuff and
then you grow up you're kind of like bro
none of that was even real like bro you
can't even do any of that you do you
watch mcgruber at all remember those no
wait what's mcber that's the takeoff on
myy okay yeah from Cent live and then
they made that into a show too yeah yeah
I saw I saw part pretty funny the movie
is funny watch mcgruber the movie is
very funny it would be probably I would
think it's way funny now because back in
the day mccyber was you took it
seriously oh yeah he used chewing gum
and a piece of yarn to dismantle that
nuclear bomb
you know it's kind of harsh sometimes I
I got my during Co got my youngest
daughter all hyped to watch ET like oh
my gosh like we're GNA have a night
tonight if I would have known about
clown soup what is that popcorn M&M's
clown salad clown if I would have known
that about that I would have done clown
soup is something very very different I
don't want to describe it here because
it's kind
of gets a little dark so I get my
daughter all hyped for et and you know
she was whatever 11 or something at the
time and we sit down and watch it and it
is so bad I mean it's it's so bad I know
talking I know I know go it holds up it
does hold up I watched it with my son
it's great when 10 years ago okay it
still held up probably 10 years ago if
you go watch it right now it's rough man
that's all I'm saying it's rough but
there's a factor with this though so and
you talk kind of we're talking about it
earlier where this there's this factor I
think it's not a secret or nothing like
that but back in the day when you went
in the movie movie theater the lights
turn out you know turned down it's like
bro you're locked in so your attention
span kind of was required for the whole
two hours right and we were all cool
with that because think about how you
watch TV right same deal where bro you
can't pause DVR watch it later watch it
when I want bro it was on and you watch
the thing and okay maybe later on you
got the VCR you record it okay but
that's a pain in ass generally speaking
you're just watching it go and if you
missed it you missed it so you better be
paying attention all two hours by the
way yeah no it's different
our brains are trained different and the
kids that's how they develop now so now
they don't need BR two hours of this
sometimes I find myself watching a show
and watching a YouTube video at the same
time you need help bro you need more
therapy I really do that's real no I
think that's kind of it's real right and
then if I miss something on the show
I'll pause it and then I'll just go back
and like what did they say about the
thing exactly right that's exactly right
now think of now think of like writing
and producing and stuff now it has to
accommodate that a little bit back in
the day didn't have to bro you character
development all day bro you ever watch
Predator the first one bro you don't see
the Predator till like freaking like an
hour into it or something like this BR
try do that no they'll be like bro this
this movie is boring I just Fe I just
now after I just called you out I
immediately had like uh internal angst
and and regret because you know what
I'll do I'll look at Zillow and watch
something like my wife and watching
something I'll be looking at Zillow like
checking properties you know what I mean
I've got like nine locations around the
country where I'm seeing if there's a
good deal today attention not required
my friend just rewind that one or watch
it freaking when it's more convenient
that's why I do love going to see movies
in a theater like it's it's it's old
school we need to we need to get back to
that sometimes go go see him I would my
kids know this I would go to like see
movies when they were little we'd go to
see whatever movie and I would 100% fall
asleep like you know I was just tired I
was working all the time and just like
I'd go in there dad's taking a nap and
whatever was and we just the last movie
we went to see as a family was it too
yeah yeah you familiar with chapter two
yeah dude I'm sorry but that that was
not a good that was freaking the first
one was pretty good but the yeah the
first one wasn't too bad but the second
one I I so I slept and when I woke up I
was like this is absolutely I remember
going to see Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs too with my son who's like
eight years old and it was so loud it
was just like meatballs and thing and I
just was like
I don't I slept through half of the
movie and it it was an assault on the
senses but it couldn't stop
me clown salad couldn't keep me awake oh
just no clown soup that's what we're
hoping anything else Echo Charles yeah
that's uh no nothing else so cool to
meet you right on thanks for rain Wilson
any closing
thoughts um I'm not kissing your ass I
love what you do I love this pod I love
your authentic self and the stories you
tell and you serve a really valuable
role and I'm honored to be on your
podcast thank you for having me well um
thanks for joining us and you know you
talked about bringing joy to people and
uh thank you for putting smiles on a lot
of people's faces including my face
including my family um like I said you
know we were going through the
war and we had a little office and that
could make us smile even in the worst of
times thanks for what you've done um
thanks for what you're doing charity the
writing the producing the acting
everything that you're doing bringing a
little bit more joy in the world much
appreciated right on thank you
thanks and with that rain Wilson has
left the
building you good Echo yes sir good
stuff interesting stuff right yeah very
interesting Journey yeah yeah I can I
think a lot of us kind of can nerd out
on on the show business side of things
especially when you watch it you know
when you watch a show and then like
you're so familiar with the show and the
characters and all this stuff and you
don't know anything not one single thing
about the behind the scenes yeah or even
about that what that person's actually
like as a human yeah it's crazy very
like that's an actor that's not who they
are yeah it's not Dwight now now there's
some you know elements in there right
like like rain even said he called on
elements of his own life to form the
character of Dwight K sh but it's still
not he's not actually Dwight K shre
right he's rain Wilson so it's very
interesting and it's weird now you think
about all those people in that
show and it comes across in the book um
you know when we were talking about like
different rock bands and how but a lot
of times rock bands like the truth comes
out right and this guy's an and
this person like was an egomaniac and
this person was like a closet drug
addict and this person was stealing all
the money like there's all these always
or often times these horrible
backstories about what's going on behind
the scenes you know what I mean yeah to
in this in reading the books like it's
like everyone's cool they're they're all
just like good people they're all so it
gives you a nice feeling right and they
all felt good and they all liked working
together and they all did a good job and
they all just enjoyed it you know so
it's kind of a good news story across
the board yeah fully but yep I felt that
same thing uh and you know I mean now
he's on this little uh spiritual journey
trying to find happiness and I'll tell
you I'm all about being happy yeah got
to be healthy got to be got be healthy
if you're having health issues you got
to do your best to get them squared away
and you want to maintain your health
pretty much that should be one of the
highest focuses of your whole life
should be being healthy if it's not it's
going to hurt you yes right right it's
going to hurt you if you're not doing
everything you can cuz look you might be
out of shape right
now but you shouldn't surrender you
should get back on the path yep so he
mentioned tennis right so it was I saw
this article it wasn't tennis it was
Table Tennis this article is what he was
talking about where table T actually you
know what yeah it was Article said table
tennis is one of the better things to do
to maintain cognitive function
interesting yeah it's a fast SP
right so your brain your hand ey
coordination and the speed and kind of
the intensity of the hand eye
coordination uh development SL
maintenance SL um stimulus is like table
tennis and I would imagine tennis even
more because you're actually riding
around with your body more yeah but it's
not as quick yes that as meticulous
right yeah that's true so but yeah they
said that like as far as cognitive
function goes bro it's like one of the
best things to maintain it please tennis
it's like damn okay well table tennis is
what you're talking ping pong the
article was about pingpong but he said
he plays tennis which to me is not very
far off do you know who juwel is yeah
juel the singer hell yeah yeah yeah uh
she was on Joe Rogan's podcast and she
was talking about she runs like a school
or like some kind of a camp or school
but to help kids and they make the kids
play tennis and she she didn't even play
tennis but she's like it's a
psychological game and I'm like oh
that's interesting that's good now look
would I prefer they Didu jitsu of course
I would of course I prefer they did the
jiujitsu of course nothing better for
the children than getting them the
Jiu-Jitsu but tennis also psychological
warfare is happening right you see John
Macken rby smashing his racket and
whatnot sure you know what I mean think
they're frustrated there's something
about tennis when you you can one
miss like in Jiu-Jitsu you make a
mistake look most of the times you can
recover from yeah yeah y it's true you
know occasionally you get caught like
you make one mistake but you already
made Seven mistakes yeah you know very
rarely does someone just catch you out
of nowhere you know and you make two
mistakes and now you're in a bad
position and now you can't recover now
they got your arm but you had three or
four chances to correct that situation
in tennis you hit in the net that's it
it's instantly dead yeah and then you
can win a bunch of points in a game and
still lose the game and you can win a
bunch of games in the set and still lose
the set and you can win multiple sets in
the match and still lose the match so
you can it's can be frustrating for some
people go to watch out wait so why did
you all start this tennis thing because
it was good psychologically oh yeah
because you got to like Focus you got to
now look again do I prefer the Jiu-Jitsu
Jiu-Jitsu I think is the number one
thing a person could do for life just to
help them but kids even more so cuz kids
they're going to be they're going to be
scrapping they're going to give be bully
situation like these things are
happening so uh that's what we're doing
we want to be
healthy on your path to happiness it's
going to be a big part of it and look
sometimes you get sideswiped you know
you get side you get hit from the you
get T-boned by like a disease you know
some health issue that's worst case
scenario but the healthier you are going
into that or if you were born with
something where it's like hey I got this
thing going on still being as healthy as
you can be is the best best possible
thing you can do so we're working out
yes sir when we're doing Jiu-Jitsu by
the way you're going to be sweating yes
you're going to need to hydrate going
need to rehydrate get yourself some jaoh
hydrate from joof fuel.com bro that's in
my everyday rotation every day you think
oh only when you sweat a lot or what no
every single day you know when I have
it sometimes I have it and I'm not
sweating sometimes I have it cuz it
tastes good yeah like at night I'll kind
of want something sweet yeah but I don't
want to have a whole milk so just have
just a little hydrate it's like a little
juice yeah little juice it's like a
little juice but it's good for you yeah
I have one in the morning with creatine
I'm on Creatine by the way oh yeah so
mix it the hydrated
creatine are you threatening me no no
just putting out word right yep hydrate
creatine good greens we get your Greens
on just you can just have greens once a
day it's a nice little way to kick
things off it's a nice little
uh bridge for me I don't do you eat
breakfast no it's a nice little Bridge a
10 o'clock bridge to get you to lunch
cuz it's a pain in the ass to stop
everything and make a Sammy right at 10
o' no get little hitter greens you're
good to go all right so there you go
joof field.com check it out get some MLK
I just had a Mulk in the break I had a
mul
see uh MLK good to go joint Warfare
super cool everything you guys know the
deal go to joof field.com get some stuff
or go to vitamin shop or go to GNC or go
to the military commissaries Apes
Haniford Dash do wake Fern shop bright
HB down in Texas Meer up in the midwest
Harris Teeter Lifetime Fitness Shields
and by the way if you got a
gym a Jiu-Jitsu gym CrossFit gym
weightlifting gym whatever you got if
you got one and you want to sell Jaco
fuel there so you can help your students
and your clients get
better email JF sales joof fuel.com get
yourself some stuff set up a wholesale
account or if you go to one of those
places and you want them to have it tell
them that's so you can make it happen
there you go joof fuel.com get
some also origin if you want
americanmade stuff from like you don't
want to support all this crazy offshore
slave labor type stuff with your
products which you probably are in one
way or another mhm it's hard to avoid
nowadays it's true but hey you need some
relief from that origin usa.com when you
get your jeans you'll know that
everything about these jeans everything
from the cotton that was harvested all
the way to the person who made them with
pride by the way skill and pride made
them here in America American made you
can get a ghee Jiu-Jitsu ghee and it's
going to be hands down the best ghee
that you've ever had in your life it's
not even going to feel like a ghee
imagine if for your whole life you were
wearing a
burlap and
wool suit head to toe you know how wool
like real itchy yeah like a straight
jacket or something yeah something like
that let's say you were wearing that
your whole life yeah and then one day
you put on like a rash guard and how
good you would feel or like a cotton Sho
t-shirt that's what it's like when you
if you've been wearing a normal ghee and
you get an origin ghee that's what
you're going to feel like that level of
different differentiation and they keep
keep getting better too by the way so I
had the rifty remember the rift came out
we're all like oh man no way no way
anyone can top this one right here cuz
like the cut and like the the Fab like
the form the whole deal it's topped oh
yeah so I would just use that every
single time yeah the riy the riy the riy
and then the Nano Pearl came out I was
like o okay so you guys just keep
getting making them better and better I
get it I see what you guys are doing we
ain't playing Orin usa.com go get
yourself some gear whatever you need to
wear on your body and don't forget about
Joost store.com that's what Echo Charles
made up yeah well it's your name but
yeah but you made up the name of the
store Super Creative Joost
store.com that's where you can get your
discipline equals Freedom hey you want
to uh you want to support the X flag
defc that's where you can get it good
thing to represent the idea of good
which is very prevalent nowadays yeah
you know rain said that at one point he
went through his whole experience and
he's like I went through all this good
and I was like wait is this a reference
to the good thing and but I didn't like
say anything and then we just moved on I
had some other thing but maybe he was in
the game maybe he was saying good the
way we say Good Very Poss I think he was
and even if he wasn't it was an
alignment cuz he went through this
terrible situation freaking bombed at
Broadway did crap Y and he was like all
that stuff happened and he went all this
bad stuff
happened good CU that led him to the
rest of his life yes sir that's what
happens imagine if he went down the
other direction I can't believe this
happening me right yeah drinking doing
cocaine exactly could have gone
wild bro but he got it back together
it's true so man yeah the alignment
exactly right so it actually doesn't
even matter whe whether he was
referencing your thing or not is it even
your thing it's a thing mhm it's true
the thing so yeah if you want to
represent you got some shirts we got you
know some cool stuff on there Joost
store.com also the shirt Locker people
seem to like been a lot of requests
lately hasn't few request yes yes
shlocker what it is if you don't know a
new shirt every month the designs are
cool people kind of like well sometimes
we go a little bit um deep you know we
should make a freaking uh something like
you were talking about going off how
many levels do you have to go off of the
office right like how many levels before
you're clear yeah we should do something
like that from the office or Yeah Yeah
from The Office go far enough away from
the office make up our own thing about
the office like like the sh Farms like
there's another farm that beats with
shro Farms right and we can make their
t-shirt right right like the truly the
best beats in pencilvania no matter what
any other places say yeah no matter what
other places say and we can make a cool
and we could do that a bunch of those
kind of look I don't want to get too
crazy but let's face it you know it's
not nothing you know the world's real
best boss right here you know like sell
a coffee mug you see what I'm saying so
we just need to go off one more level
one level of one level
of of removal yeah plausible deniability
like we don't know what you're were
talking about we just thought it'd be
funny to have a beat Farm in
Pennsylvania yeah right yeah what are
they going to say sue us they're not
even going after the Etsy people or the
Amazon people I wonder you know how you
look at Joo t-shirts and there's a bunch
of freaking ripoffs on Amazon Joo uh
Navy SEAL inspired t-shirts yeah that
literally say Joo on them yeah well
don't get those t-shirts but they he
said they don't go after you know
whoever owns NBC doesn't go after the
Amazon people that are selling Dwight K
shrew T-shirts they should be it kind of
sucks for
him yeah you figure yeah you know what
what they call it name likeness right
name image likeness or whatever kind of
a scenario I guess the image and
likeness kind of thing well either way
hey look to me hey man if you could go
on the other Spectrum or the other side
of the spectrum where it's like hey if
you made it better than than how we made
it that's your right get the better one
up to you you know but either way let's
let's um let's just keep an open mind
and we can we can request ideas if you
have a good idea for a on level removed
office t-shirt will make it and we'll
send it to rain and we'll be like rain
you don't need to take any of this
from NBC anymore you're going to be in
the game one layer removed prove it yeah
prove that we're talking about shuit
Farms we're not we're talking about the
best beats in Pennsylvania yeah you know
not what the other guy sells well we
don't like beats bro we like beats all
day but yes that's what you're going to
get we love beats y it's true Locker sh
Locker get some uh subscribe to the
podcast subscribe to Jaco underground
subscribe to the YouTube channels
subscribe to psychological warfare which
is actually an iTunes thing that we put
out a long time ago long and for a while
I was like oh I'm going to make another
one and I still haven't looks like I
need more disc discipline in my life
psychological warfare out there on
iTunes and whatnot Flipside canvas
Dakota Meyer making cool stuff to hang
on your wall from an American hero
americanmade that's what we're talking
about also books clearly today we
covered the bassoon King and soul Boom
by rain
Wilson good reads funny reads check them
out final spin I wrote a novel a lot of
people think it's one of the best novels
ever written that's what a that's what
I've been hearing so get on that a bunch
of other books you guys know what they
are get the warrior kid books Warrior
Kid 1 2 3 four and five Mikey and the
dragons these are books for your
children help them help them figure
things out also ason front we have a
leadership consultancy we solve problems
through leadership go to ashon front.com
if you need help with leadership inside
your organization also we have Live
Events we've
got well the Dallas October muster sold
out a while ago the next one's in San
Diego it's not sold out yet but it will
be so check that out women's assembly I
think there's a couple seats left no
there won't be by the time this comes
out it'll be over so
anyways eamf front.com that's what we do
we also have an online Training Academy
at extreme ownership. comom learning the
lessons of leadership for business and
life you can do it online you really can
you really can get educated online it's
a true thing it's not uh a
fantasy it actually works we've had
incredible feedback on that go to
extreme ownership. if you want to be
educated about leadership online and if
you want to help service members active
and retired you want to help their
families you want to help gold star
families check out Mark Le's mom mama
Lee She's Got an incredible charity
organization and if you want to donate
or you want to get involved go to
Americas Mighty warriors.org also heroes
and horses mic think just got his latest
class out of the field where they went
into the
Wilderness and got lost and got
found Heroes and horses. org if you want
to connect with us rain Wilson
is atou boo.com he's also got an
Instagram and a Twitter at rain Wilson
he's got a Facebook at rain Wilson he's
got a TV show which we're not allowed to
promote but if we were promoting it it
would be called the geography of bliss
it's on the peacock
Network and if you want to connect with
Eko he's that Echo Charles and I am at
Joo willink just be careful because
there's an algorithm there and it'll
grab you by the throat and it'll put you
to sleep and when you wake up you'll
have wasted your life and you don't want
that thanks again to rain Wilson for
joining us we got him stuck in traffic
on the way back he's got a long drive
he's sitting in traffic it's miserable
right now apologize for that Mr rain
Wilson but thank you for joining us
sorry it took so long appreciate the
lessons from your journey and thanks for
making us all laugh and feel little Joy
along the way and thanks to the members
of our army navy Air Force Marines we
can live our lives because of the
dedication you have made with your lives
and we thank you for it also thanks to
our police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correct
officers boorder Patrol Secret Service
and all First Responders thank you for
your
dedication to keep us safe here at home
and everyone else out
there I'm going to leave you with a
couple
quotes a couple
quotes from Dwight K sh number one
whenever I think about whenever I'm
about to do something I think would an
idiot do that and if they would I do not
do that thing there you go that's quote
number one this is actually important I
said something similar recently don't do
dumb it's a very similar thing this
one takes a little bit more thought but
it's a good thing to think about and
then here's another quote in the wild
there is no Health Care in the wild
Health Care is ow I hurt my leg I can't
run an i a lion eats me and I'm dead
well I'm not dead I'm the lion you're
dead
so there you go don't do dumb don't
do things that an idiot would do and
then be the
lion and that's all we've got for now
and until next time this is Ekko and Joo
out